WILL BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING FOR THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE WE HAVE. A NOT ONLY A
QUORUM BUT EVERYBODY IN
ATTENDANCE HERE FOR FINAL
HEARING OF THE YEAR PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE. MCCARTY HERE
GALLAGHER. LEAD MEDINA
O'DONNELL RAYOS BY THE ARTIST.
OKAY FIRST OF ALL I THINK ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
NOT ONLY BEING HERE TODAY BUT
YOUR PARTICIPATION THROUGH
THESE PAST FEW MONTHS SO
TODAY'S ACTIONS ARE A
CULMINATION OF THIS WORK
HEARING THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSALS- ON TOP OF THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSALS BUT
YOU'RE FRANKLY MORE IMPORTANTLY
HEARING OUR PROPOSALS HEARING
OUR IDEAS GETTING OUR INPUT. AS
WELL AS HEARING INPUT FROM THE
PUBLIC SO WE HAVE A CHANCE HERE
TODAY TO VOTE ON ON THE
PROPOSED BUDGET FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE RELATE TO
EDUCATION FROM EARLY EDUCATE
WHAT THE HIRING AND DO IT ALL
TODAY. AND JUST THE BIG PICTURE
THIS OF COURSE IS A HISTORIC
BUDGET ONE THAT WE FRANKLY HAVE
A ONCE IN A GENERATION MAYBE A
POLITICAL GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME
TRANSFORMATIONAL INVESTMENTS IN
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM I
WITH THIS YEAH I CAN I'M A GOON
FOR CALIFORNIANS OUT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WEALTHIEST
INDIVIDUALS- ESSENTIALLY GIVING
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK WHAT
WE HAVE IN THE BUDGET TO TAKE
SOME LONG TERM INVESTMENTS IN
OUR KIDS AND OUR FUTURE- THIS
IS FRANKLY WHY LOT OF US WERE
ELECTED TO MAKE SOME OF THESE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS TO HAVE. A
HIGH WATER MARK IN IN IN
FUNDING FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
TO MAKE TRANSFORMATIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY EDUCATION
GOING AFTER A UNIVERSAL
UNIVERSAL EARLY EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA THE
FUNDING AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
FOR ALL KIDS TO EXPANDING
HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESS AND
POTENTIALLY MAKING COLLEGE DEBT
FREE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
LOT. THAT EXCITED- BUT THE
BIGGEST ISSUE FOR OUR FAMILIES
OF COURSE AFTER THE PANDEMIC IS
GETTING BACK. TO TO SCHOOL AND
THAT CERTAINLY PART. OF THE- OF
THE BUDGET PLAN BEFORE US TODAY.
WITH THE FUNDING WOULD TWENTY
BILLION MORE FOR PROP NINETY
EIGHT- RESOURCES FOR OUR
SCHOOLS- ABOVE LAST YEAR
ALLOWING US TO. GO FROM ZOOM
SCHOOL TO REAL SCHOOL- THIS
FALL SOME OF THE MAJOR PIECES
THAT WERE I THINK VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT I AND I'M EXCITED
ABOUT AND FRANKLY IS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT AROUND ON SEVEN
YEARS AGO SO THIS ISN'T AN
AMAZING DAY BEING. THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE TAKING SOME IS
ACTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR YEARS NOT JUST ME
SOME OF THESE ISSUES CALIFORNIA
TALKING ABOUT FOR DECADES OF.
TODAY WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE AND FIND A UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
CALIFORNIA- UNIVERSAL ACCESS
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS. WE WILL
HAVE A MASSIVE EXPANSION OF
CHILD CARE IN CALIFORNIA TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW SLOTS. WE
WILL HAVE E. C. E. RATE REFORM
FOR CHILDCARE AND PRE K.
PROGRAMS TO. FINANCIALLY
STABILIZE- THE FIELD ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
PAY ARE YOU SEE PROFESSIONALS
LIVING WAGES. I WILL DOUBLE
FUNDING FOR OUR HIGH SCHOOL
CAREERS- THE HIGH SCHOOL A CITY
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS I SAID
EARLIER PROVIDING. THE MOST
MONEY EVER FOR OUR K. TWELVE
SYSTEM THROUGH OUR LCF FUNDING
FORMULA. HAVE A PATH FOR
UNIVERSAL ACCESS FOR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL. WE
FIND GROW AND COLA- AS WELL AS-
IMPORTANT CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
FOR UC AND CSU SYSTEMS FULLY
FUNDING THE SYSTEM REQUESTS-
ROUTE AND ALSO WILL BE COMING
BACK IN DEALING WITH AN ISSUE
THAT CAN THE COMING WEEKS ON. A
ENROLLMENT STUDENT HOUSING
EXPANSION AS WELL AS FINANCIAL
AID REFORM AND A PATH TO DEBT
FREE COLLEGE- BUT WITH THAT
WITH THATTODAY WE WILL BEGIN
WITH OUR WITH OUR ITEMS WE HAVE
A LOT TO COVERED. TODAY A LOT
OF VOTE ONLY ITEMS THAT WE
HEARD EARLIER. IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING-
CERTAINLY- THOSE ARE THESE ARE
VOTE ONLY FOR THE MEMBERS HERE
TODAY NOT NO DISCUSSION. WE
WILL HAVE SOME ARE PROPOSED
ACTION ITEMS LATER THAT WE CAN
CERTAINLY HAVE DISCUSSION ON
THESE. THIS IS THE OF COURSE
SAY A PUBLIC HEARING WE VALUE
PUBLIC COMMENTS- I THINK WE'LL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM. FOR CERTAINLY VIA
PHONE- CAN PARTICIPATE AT THE
END OF THE COMMITTEE HEARING.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ALL THE ITEMS- CHILD
CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION K.
TWELVE HIGHER ED ON EVERYTHING
AT THE VERY END. SO IF YOU WANT
THE NUMBER NOW IT'S ON THE
AGENDA YOU CAN GO TO OUR THE
GENDER GO TO THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET WEBSITE TO GET IT. BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE IT. IT'S.
1-877-692-8957 ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. 626-237-2426
TWO THREE. SEVEN OKAY- WE-
START- THE ACCESS STATE AND THE
AND THE VOTING ANY. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR ANYTHING FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER S. THANK YOU SURE- BUT I
DO HAVE A QUESTION AND I KNOW
THAT I WILL FOLLOW UP-
REGARDING IT. ON THE
STABILIZATION OF FUNDING AND I
KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION REGARDING THAT-
ABOUT THE USE OF THE FUNDS. FOR
THE EARLY EDUCATION
STABILIZATION FUNDING YES OKAY.
WHAT WHAT NOT BECAUSE THAT ON
THE BOTTOM. YEAH AND I'LL
ADDRESS THAT WHEN WE GET OKAY
PERFECT THANK YOU. YES A NUMBER
OF ITEMS. AM I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT WE IF WE COULD
PULL OF THOSE SEPARATELY ON
ITEMS. FORTY TO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY SIX AND EIGHTY FOUR OUT
OF THE ORDINARY. THANK YOU. BUT
JUST ANY INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS
LIKE YOU HAD A GREAT TIME THIS
YEAR GREAT FIRST YEAR
EVERYTHING ANY BETTER THAN THIS
SO FAR SPENDING ANY MONEY WHICH
IS ALL TRUE MR MEDINA YEAH WHEN
I THANK THE CHAIR FOR A GREAT
JOB. DONE BUT- SO. BUT A
QUESTION- TO FIND OUT WHEN IS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO SPEAK
ON ON ITEMS YES YES SO WE'RE
GONNA DO THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS
RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY ITEMS ONE THROUGH A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE AND THESE
ARE ITEMS THAT WE HEARD DURING.
THE- DURING THE SPRING- AND
THEN FOR THE ACTION ITEMS AFTER
THAT WE WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
DISCUSS THEMSELVES SO IF I
WANTED TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
ETHNIC STUDIES FUNDING. THIS BE
THE APPROPRIATE TIME- WHAT WHAT
WHAT. DESCRIPTION NOT NOT
WITHOUT A LITTLE. YEAH THAT'LL
BE LATER. NOW TO BE A BIT LATER
OKAY. OKAY SOMEONE I RESPECTED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO
WANT TO SHARE- I AGREE WITH
MIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
RIVERSIDE THE THIS PACKAGE
MAKES MONUMENTAL INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE SYSTEM. AND I DO APPLAUDED
THE COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO THESE DETAILS
AND THE COMMITTEE REGARDING THE
PROPOSALS THAT WILL ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
THEIR FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS.
EVEN AS THEY'RE STRUGGLING
DURING THIS PANDEMIC
SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO TELL YOU
HOW THRILLED I AM THAT THERE
ARE A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILD CARE SPACES TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE FOR
FAMILIES OF ALL BACKGROUNDS. AS
WELL AS THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM SLOTS. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS AGO ALSO AB
NINETY TWO MY FAMILY FEES BILL
I'M VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT
THAT IS INCLUDED IN THE IN THE
PROPOSAL- THE FASTER AND KEITA
COMPLETION I AM VERY PLEASED TO
SEE THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WILL ALSO BE INCLUDED IN. AS
NOTED IN THE BUDGET SO BUT THE
JUST THE INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE
MAKING IN CHILD CARE IN OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR FAMILIES I AM
VERY PLEASED WITH THAT AND- FOR
THAT I THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU. SAYING THAT MR GALLAGHER
YES- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT THE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR THE WORK THAT I
THINK WE DID VERY WELL THIS
YEAR ALWAYS- ENJOY THIS
COMMITTEE AND I THINK IT'S-
THAT WE COME TOGETHER IN A VERY
BIPARTISAN WAY- TO. YOU KNOW I
REALLY THINK MAKE VERY HELPFUL
AND IMPORTANT CHANGES IN THE
BUDGET- FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION SYSTEM. ARE JUST A
COUPLE THINGS I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE- INCREASING
THE FUNDING FOR CTE. PROGRAMS
WHICH WE'VE ALWAYS MADE A
PRIORITY- IT IN THIS SUB
COMMITTEE- ALSO I THINK MAKING
SOME GOOD IMPORTANT CHANGES ON
CHILD CARE. ON THE SLOTS ON ON
RATES- WITH THESE PROPOSAL
TODAY AT TODAY- AND THEN- THE
FINAL ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
WHICH I THINK WOULD BE A WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED A LOT
THE NEED FOR- IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS. ACTUALLY DUCATION
TO TRULY GET- TWO WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THERE YET BUT TO TRULY-
EQUALIZATION OF FUNDING- AND
WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS IN THAT-
ON THAT FRONT SO I APPRECIATE
THOSE THAT THOSE IMPROVEMENTS I
THINK WE'VE MADE THIS BUDGET-
WITH THESE ITEMS TODAY. I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
ON OF THESE AND OTHER ITEMS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU SOMEONE REMIND US. I
WILL DECIDE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I'VE HAD A REALLY
GREAT YOU KNOW FIRST EXPERIENCE
IN THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE AND-
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE- IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY THINK THAT
EDUCATION CAN BE VERY PARTISAN
AND I THINK WE HAVE REALLY
DONE- JUSTICE THIS YEAR AND
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES AND
HOW THEY IMPACT STUDENTS-
REALLY THROUGH TRYING TO READ
TO DO THIS THROUGH AN
NONPARTISAN LANDS AND THIS IS
WHAT CALIFORNIANS. WANT TO SEE%
S. TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION
ABOUT IMPROVING QUALITY
EXPANDING ACCESS- YOU KNOW THAT
EARLY LEARNING AND ACCESS TO
PRESCHOOL AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN IS A HUGE PARTY
FOR ME AND- WE'RE GONNA GET
THAT DONE AND IT'S A VERY PROUD
MOMENT FOR ME- FOR MY FOUR YEAR
OLD AT HOME WHO. WILL BENEFIT
THAT FROM NOT BUT ANOTHER FOUR
YEAR OLD AND A FEW YEARS WELL
SO IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
ME- I'M EXCITED ABOUT OUR WORK
COULD BE THE ONLY UNITS HAVE
YET I WANT TO AND IS. AND WITH
IT AND I ACTUALLY WANT TO THANK
OUR- AND COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
LEAD CONSULTANT FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE THIS YEAR AND
PROBABLY THE MOST CHALLENGING
YOUR THAT YOU'VE HAD. AN
EDUCATION WITH BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR HARD WORK- I DO HAVE
YOU KNOW A FEW CONCERNS AS WE-
MOVE FORWARD NOT ONLY WITH THIS
BUDGET BUT IN THE YEARS TO
COME. WE'RE SEEING SO MANY NEW
PROGRAMS AND FUNDING COMING
INTO EDUCATION AND OF THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OF OUR SURPLUS AND-
BECAUSE OF THE ONE TIME FUNDING
FROM FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE BUT- AND IT
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE REMOVING BACK
TO. THIS CATEGORICAL- SPENDING
THAT WE MOVED THAT WE TRIED TO
CHANGE TEN YEARS AGO WHAT ELSE
IF THAT FUNDING SO I WOULD JUST
CAUTION- MY COLLEAGUES. TO
LET'S NOT GET BACK TO THAT
PLACE WHERE EVERYTHING IS ABOUT
HOW TO GROW UP WITH A SPENDING-
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HARD IN OUR
DISTRICTS AND HARD IN OUR
DISTRICTS. ON THAT NEED ARE ARE
THAT. NEED APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU- YOU ARE YOU
GIVING ME TOO I'LL GET TO LATER
IN THE AGENDA BUT I DID WANT TO
THANK OUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS- AARON AND MARK AND
CAROLINE WHO- TALK TO OUR OUR
ADVOCATES IN OUR CAR
STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR STAFF-
COUNTLESS HOURS AFTER OUR
COMMITTEES AND DO A LOT OF WORK
PREPARING AGENDAS AND SO. IT'S
BEEN A VERY SEAMLESS PROCESS
AND HOPEFULLY TODAY'S FINAL DAY
WILL BE SO WANT TO GIVE THEM A
PROPER RECOGNITION- SO WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
WITH WITH THE- SOMEONE EVERLY.
THANK YOU I'LL BE BRIEF I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THIS IS INDEED
A MONUMENTAL BUDGET PROPOSAL-
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LEADERSHIP
OF OUR CHAIR AND- LEADING THE
WAY TKA EDUCATIONS I COMMEND
YOU FOR THAT. BUT I THINK IT'S
ALSO AN IMPORTANT FUNCTION THAT
AS THERE ARE FOLKS WHO DO
REALLY WELL IN OUR ECONOMY THAT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GIVE US A
TEMPORARY LIFT. A TEMPER LEFT
IN OUR AND A SURPLUS IN OUR
BUDGET IS IMPORTANT I THINK AND
DEMONSTRATE OUR VALUES HERE
THAT WE ARE REINVESTING THAT
SURPLUS INTO OUR FUTURE INTO
OUR CHILDREN. I THINK THERE ARE
VERY FEW PRIORITIES IN THIS
WORLD THAT ARE MORE FOR THE
CHILDREN THEN THE EDUCATION AND
FUTURE OF OUR CHILDREN SO IT'S
SMART TO REINVEST AND AS
THINGS. LIKE I SEE WITH- ITEM
THAT WE'RE GONNA VOTE ON LATER
ITEM SEVEN WHICH IS IN CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION JOINT
POWERS AGREEMENTS. I'M GLAD
THEY'LL BE EIGHTY SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS BUT- WITH
MY DISTRICT I OF METRO ED WHICH
IS A ONE OF THOSE GPA. A CITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE SIX
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN MY DISTRICT
AND THE ADJACENT DISTRICTS AND
IS THE ONLY C. T. PROGRAM IN
THE ENTIRE SILICON VALLEY. I
HOPE WE'LL BE ABLE TO
APPROPRIATE IN THE FUTURE EVEN
MORE MONEY TO THAT BECAUSE
DEFINITELY MORE MORE SINCE
DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
C. T. EDUCATION ESPECIALLY IN.
A LOT OF PLACES THAT GENERATE
SO MUCH OF OUR GREAT STIMULUS
SOMEONE'S ARE GREAT SURPLUS FOR
ENTIRE STATES SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER. YES THANK YOU.
OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING TO. START
ON THE VOTE ONLY SECTIONS THESE
ARE ISSUES THAT WE HEARD FROM
THE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
FROM THE GOVERNOR AND OR THE
NAY REVISE. A WE WON'T HAVE
DISCUSSION IS JUST VOTE ONLY.
SO THE FIRST ISSUE IS ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THIS IS ESSENTIALLY
PAGES TWO THREE THIRTY NINE.
THERE ARE TWELVE- THERE ARE A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE. ISSUES ON
THIS ON THIS ON THIS CATEGORY-
LOOKING FOR A AND THIS IS
RELATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION-
VARIOUS T. K. THROUGH TWELVE
LOCAL ASSISTED IN STATE OFFICE-
INITIATIVES AND PROGRAMS SAID.
LOOKING FOR A MOTION A SECOND
ON THIS SECTION. OKAY WE HAVE A
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MY SUMMER REYES. AND THEN IF
THERE'S ANY ITEMS THAT YOU YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE OFF A NOT.
VOTE ON. A ITEMS ONE. THROUGH
ONE TWELVE. IF YOU COULD JUST
NOTIFY US NOW. A TO PULL ITEM
OF ITEMS FORTY TO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY SIX AND EIGHTY FOUR
FULL AS AND YOU'LL BE VOTING
YOU ARE NOT INDEPENDENT ENOUGH
TO BEAT IT I WOULD LIKE TO GO
ON THOSE INDEPENDENTLY. OKAY
PERFECT. AND WHEN YOU SAY ONE
THREE ONE OR TWELVE DO YOU JUST
MEAN ON THE FIRST VOTE ON THE
ISSUE NUMBER ONE YEAH THE FIRST
ISSUE ISSUE VOTE ONLY ISSUE ONE
HAS A HUNDRED AND TWELVE ITEMS.
HUNDRED I'M SORRY HUNDRED AND.
ONE HUNDRED TWELVE ITEMS THAT
THAT'S ON YOUR AGENDA PAGE.
THREE THREE THIRTY NINE. OKAY-
YES I WOULD LIKE TO PULL. VERY
WELL. TWELVE THIRTEEN. THE
FORTY TWO HAS ALREADY ASKED FOR
SELLING WHEN YOU SAY PALMER
JUST CLARIFYING THAT MEANS
YOU'RE GONNA NOT DEPENDENT UPON
IT NOW ON THESE WERE NOT VOTE
OR NOT VOTE YEAH OKAY SIXTY
EIGHT. SIXTY NINE SEVENTY SIX.
EIGHTY FOUR. EIGHTY SIX. AND I
THINK THAT'S IT OKAY SO CLARIFY
THAT MR GALLAGHER IS VOTING NO
ON THOSE ITEMS- SUMMER BY
AADHAR IS VOTING NO ITEMS SHE-
PRODUCTS ARE ATTENTION AND THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE VOTING HIGH ON ITEMS ONE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWELVE ON THE
VOTE ONLY ISSUE ONE. LIKE TO
CLARIFY HERE YEAH SO VALLADARES
WE FIGHTING WILL BE VOTING NO
ON ITEMS FORTY TWO AND EIGHTY
SIX AND I WILL NOT BE VOTING ON
ITEMS SEVENTY SIX AND EIGHTY
FOUR. YEAH PERFECT THANK YOU.
OKAY SO NOW WE KIND OF GET THE
FLOW THIS SO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
IS THAT T. K. THREE. TWELVE
OMNIBUS TRAILER BILL THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY ITEM. NUMBER
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THROUGH
ITEM NUMBER HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT SO ON THE AGENDA IT'S
PAGE FORTY THROUGH FORTY EIGHT
SO WE HAVE LOOKING FOR A MOTION
A MOTION FOR MISTER LEE AND A
SECOND FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMOS ON VOTE ONLY ISSUE NUMBER
TWO ARE THERE ANY OBJECTIONS TO
ANY OF THESE ITEMS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF ITEMS THAT ASSEMBLY.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOT VOTE ON
ITEMS ONE THIRTY AND ONE THIRTY
ONE. ONE GALLAGHER NO. OKAY.
OKAY SO ALL THE OTHER. FOUR
DEMOCRATS I SEE OUR SUPPORTING
CAST MEDINA MISTER O'DONNELL
AND THEN WE HAD THE MOTION
SECOND FROM RIGHT ASSEMBLY.
MISTER DONALD CORRECT YES OKAY
SO ALL THE OTHER MEMBERS ARE
VOTING I FOR THOSE ITEMS. ONE
THIRTEEN THROUGH ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. THE REPUBLICAN PROPOSAL.
INTERESTING CLEVELAND GO AHEAD
AND JUST COPY APPLE ONE SHERMAN
SO FOR ISSUE NUMBER ONE WE HAD.
THE- THAT THE MOTION. AND THE
SECOND FOR ISSUES- TWO ONE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWELVE WITH
THAT AND- WE'LL WE'LL START
WE'LL WE'LL START OVER AND I'M
SORRY WILL TAKE AS OPPOSED TO
JUST THE REFERENCES WILL TAKE
AN ACTUAL VOTE ON THE CELL.
MOTION A SECOND- MRS DESPITE
ADDISON GALLAGHER NOTED THE
ONES THEY WILL BE VOTING FOR SO
YOU PLEASE CALL ROLE ON THE
OTHERS. PARISHIONER ONE MCCARTY
HI GALLAGHER. LEE MEDINA FOR
DONALD REYES FIVE HOURS OKAY
MINUS THE ISSUES THAT GALLAGHER
AND I INTERESTED IN AGAIN FOR
ISSUE NUMBER TWO HOW WE HAD THE
MOST IN THE SECONDS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. RIGHT ARSON GALLAGHER.
IF YOU AND REBEKAH ONES THE
THING YEAH WITH A NATION
NUMBERS THE ISSUE THE ISSUE
VOTE ONLY NUMBER TWO WITHOUT
HURTING NO ONE ONE THIRTY ONE
THAT B THERE IS THAT NOT
VOTING ON ONE THIRTY AND ONE
THIRTY ONE YES OKAY SAID MOST.
OF THE SECOND THIS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MCCARTY HI GALLAGHER.
PLEASE MEDINA O'DONNELL REYES
BY THE- OKAY THANK YOU THANKS
FOR THE PATIENCE AFTER A LITTLE
CHOPPY STARTUP WE'LL GET IT
BACK GOING ON HERE OKAY ISSUE
NUMBER THREE THIS IS THE- THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
THIS IS- SENSUALLY ISSUES A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE THROUGH.
OUR ITEMS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE THROUGH ONE FIFTY TWO
AGENDA PAGE FORTY NINE THREE
FIFTY TWO DO WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND ON THE CTC. ITEMS MOTION
BY SUMMER BY A DIREST THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
DO WE HAVE ANY ITEMS THAT WE
ANYBODY WHICH IS TO NOT VOTE ON
HERE. SEEING NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MCCARTY HI GALLAGHER.
PLEASE MEDINA. DONALD REYES BY
THE FIRST. OKAY ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR THE VOTE ONLY SECTION THIS
IS THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. THIS IS ITEMS.
ONE FIFTY THREE AND ONE FIFTY
FOUR ON- PAGE NUMBER FIFTY
THREE. I DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS. POSTED BY BIDAR SECOND BY
LEE ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
ON THESE TWO ITEMS. SING NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MCCARTY
HI GALLAGHER. LEE MEDINA THE
DONALD REYES BY THE FIRST. OKAY
THIS IS THE VOTE ONLY ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES CHILD CARE AND
STATE OPS THESE ARE ITEMS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE. THROUGH
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE. PAGE
FIFTY FIVE ON THE AGENDA. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND FOR
THE SIDE. MOTION BY BY ADARA
SECOND BY RAMOS ANY CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS AN EIGHTIES I'D- SAY
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HI GALLAGHER. PLEASE
MEDINA DONALD REYES FIVE HOURS.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER. SIX REALLY
CARE STATE OPS THESE ARE ITEMS
NUMBER OF HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO. THROUGH ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY BASE FIFTY EIGHT OF
MAGENTA. WE HAVE A MOTION FIVE
BY TARA SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER
LEE DO WE HAVE ANY. CONCERNS ON
ANY OF THESE ITEMS. SING NINE
PLEASE FOLLOW. MCCARTY HI
GALLAGHER. LEE MEDINA DONALD
REYES MY FIRST. OKAY SO THAT
WRAPS UP THE VOTE ONLY A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ITEMS THAT
WE DISCUSSED THIS SPRING DURING
HEARINGS AND NEXT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO. THE ITEMS TO BE HEARD
TODAY.
OKAY SO THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY THE MEAT OF OUR
WORK TODAY FOCUSING ON THE
PRIORITIES OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND MEMBERS
ADDING ON TO THE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
RELATED TO A PUBLIC EDUCATION-
THE FIRST THING THAT WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME THIS YEAR I WANT TO
FLAG IS THE RE OPENING. OF OUR
SCHOOLS AS A SAFER YOU OPENING
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET FULLY
SUPPORTS SAY FREE OPENING OF
OUR SCHOOLS THIS FALL WILL BE
ADOPTING PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO STRENGTHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
ABOUT SKI SCHOOL RE OPENING. IN
THE MAY REVISION. AND WHILE WE-
FULLY FUND THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE- IN THIS BUDGET
THERE ARE KEY. ELEMENTS THAT
GO. ABOVE AND BEYOND- SOMEWHAT-
MODIFY THE GOT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS. THAT WERE USING THE-
L. A. O. REVENUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET ASSUMES ONE
POINT TWO BILLION A ONE TIME
PROP TWO PAYMENTS TO SCHOOLS.
TO OFFSET THE FUTURE COSTS FOR
PENSIONS- WE HAVE A- COST OF
LIVING- FOR. A LITTLE OVER 4%
FOR ALL STATUTORY COLOR
PROGRAMS INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL AND AFTER
SCHOOL ACES PROGRAMS AND ADULT
EDUCATION. WE AMANDA MAY
REVISED TO INCREASE THE L. C.
F. F. CONCENTRATION RATE. AND
ADOPTED ONGOING INCREASED L.
CFF SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT RATE OF
ONE POINT ONE BILLION. AND
ADDRESS THE GROWTH RATE TO.
TWENTY DEGREES SUPPLEMENTAL
GROWTH RATE TO TWENTY THREE
POINT 3% WE PAID OUT ALL T. T.
K. THROUGH TWELVE DEFERRALS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR- AS NOTED
EARLIER THIS THIS BUDGET-
EMBRACES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WE
SLIGHTLY A MAN'S. THE THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL BY EXTENDING
THE TIMELINE FOR FULL
IMPLEMENTATION TO THE TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX SCHOOL YEAR WE
INCREASED A UNIVERSAL T. K.
MINIMUM QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
FULL FOR FULL DAY REQUIRE ONE
TO TEN ADULT TO CHILD RATIO AND
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FULL DAY. FULL YEAR WRAP CARE
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR TEA CASE
STUDENTS IN KINDERGARTEN
STUDENTS HAVE CARE AFTER SCHOOL
IF THEIR PARENTS HAVE WORK
OBLIGATIONS AND WE MAINTAIN
ELIGIBILITY. WHICH WE'VE HEARD
LOUD AND CLEAR THESE PAST FEW
MONTHS FOR CHILD. AND PARENT
ELIGIBILITY TO STILL ACCESS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL AND
HEAD START PROGRAMS FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS. WE HAVE- WE COMBINE
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
PUZZLES AS FAR AS EARLY
EDUCATION PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT. AND THE
CALIFORNIA TRADITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PLANNING GRANTS
WITH THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
NOTED EARLIER WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TO EXPAND PROP
NINETY EIGHT SUPPORT FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. FOR FULL DAY FULL YEAR
SLOTS FOR BOTH THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS- ANOTHER BIG
PRIORITIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE
NOTED. AND ONE OF THE LINCHPINS
OF OUR EARLY ED PACKAGES MAKING
SURE THAT WE ADJUST RATES FOR
OUR CHILD CARE AND STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS WHICH WILL
AGAIN STABILIZE THESE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS ENSURE-THAT ARE YOU SEE PROFESSIONALS
ARE PAID LIVING WAGES- WE ADOPT
THE NAY REVISED SUPER COLOR FOR
SPECIAL ADDED. FOUR FOUR POINT
005% THE INCREASE ED FUNDING BY
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
HUNDRED NINETY ONE MILLION ON
GOING. IN ADDITION TO THE BASE
FUNDING GROWTH FOR SPECIAL
LEARNING RECOVERY WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS IN A ONE TIME
BASIS- WE PROVIDE TWENTY
MILLION ONE TIME PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDS. FOR THE SUPPORTIVE
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES AND
PROVIDE. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION A
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPENSIVE PROGRAM. WE PROVIDE
AS I NOTED EARLIER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW MONEY. TO DOUBLE THE
SUPPORT FOR HIGH SCHOOL CTE
PROGRAMS. WE PROVIDE ONE TIME
MONEY OF SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR COLLEGE
WRITING THIS FOR THE A. THREE
G. COMPLETION GRANT PROGRAM.
WHICH COVERS CREDIT RECOVERY
EIGHT THREE G. COURSE CAPACITY
AND COVER áP FEES FOR THE
EIGHTIES TUNE EXAMS TO PRIORITY
OF MINE- WE EXPANDED EXPANDED
LEARNING WEEKS WE EXT WE AMEND
THE MAY REVISE PROPOSAL FOR ONE
BILLION FOR EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS. THIS ALIGNS WITH OUR
ACES- PROGRAMS AND QUALITY
STANDARDS AND WHAT PUT US ON A
PATH TO HAVE UNIVERSAL- AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. WE EMBRACE THE
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS.
ASSEMBLY ADOPTS THE SENATE
PROPOSAL INCREASE STATE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WILL
PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONGOING PROP NINETY
EIGHT. FOR THESE EFFORTS. WE
APPROVE THE MAY REVISION OPPOSE
ALL FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
L. G. B. T. Q. PLUS CULTURAL
COMPETENCY ONLINE- PROGRAM. WE
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO-
IMPLEMENTED ENACT ETHNIC
STUDIES IN CALIFORNIA. AS WELL
AS MAKE- AVAILABLE PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDS IN THE BLOCK GRANTS
TO HELP WITH- PARTICIPATION IN
PROFESSIONAL ELEMENT TRAFFIC
STUDIES. AND LAST AND- AND THEN
WE PROVIDE RESOURCES AND
ONGOING POP NINETY EIGHT TO
ADMINISTER THIS THE SEAL OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT- TWO ISSUES
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING THAT WE-
THAT WE REJECT FROM THE MAY
REVISE. OUR THE IN PERSON
HEALTH AND SAFETY BLOCK GRANT
AND THE TARGETED INTERVENTION
GRANTS. AS FAR AS STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLBEING WE
SUPPORT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND
MODIFY THE NEIGHBOR REVISED
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWO BILLION
ONE TIME FUNDING TO ALIGN
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS THROUGH
THE HEALTHY START PROGRAM.
THAT'S OUR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PROPOSAL- WE PROVIDE RESOURCES
TEN MILLION PROP NINETY EIGHT
ONE TIME FOR THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS.
FOR EDUCATOR PIPELINE A
PROFESSIONAL SUPPORT FOR OUR
TEACHER TRAINING PROGRAMS WE
DEMAND AND HAVE REMAINED THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ONE BILLION
ONE TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR
EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM. AND ADD EARLY
CHILD EDUCATION THREE THREE TO
THE- TO THE PROPOSAL. AND AS
WELL AS ETHNIC STUDIES AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER AS FAR AS AN
ALLOWABLE USE. I WOULD PROVIDE
A HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME-
REDUCING THE AMOUNTS I'M SORRY
ARE BUDGET REDUCES THE NAY
REVISED FUNDING TO ONE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME FOR THE
NATIONAL BOARD CERTIFICATION-
FEES FOR TEACHERS. AND THAT IS
A SNAPSHOT OF OUR. ASSEMBLY
PROP NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE SO
THESE ARE ALL- NUMBERS ONE
THROUGH- THREE TWENTY WILL FEEL
CERTAINLY- ENTERTAIN ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS OF FURTHER EXPLANATION
IN THESE ITEMS BUT WITH THAT
AND WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THE- ASSEMBLY. PROP
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET PACKAGE THE
EMOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY REYES TO
HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS ON THESE ITEMS.
PHONENUMBER GALLAGHER- ARE WE
VOTING ON THE ENTIRE NINETY
EIGHT AS THIS IS ONE VOTE YEAH
THIS IS ONE VOTE BUT AGAIN LIKE
TO VOTE ONLY YOU CAN PEEL OFF
THE ONES THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
NOT VOTE ON FOR ONES THAT YOU
HAVE ANY AND HOW ARE THE I'M
TRYING TO SEE HOW THOSE ARE
LINED OUT QUESTION YEAH. SO IF
YOU LOOK AT THE AGENDA. IT
WOULD BE. ON THE LEFT TAKE PAGE
THE WITH THE- WITH THE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE. SIXTY ONE
ONE THE CARD SIXTY ONE MISTER
GALLAGHER OF THE AGENDA. SO
IT'S PAID SIXTY ONE. ISSUE ONE.
AND THE ITEMS ARE NUMBERED. ONE
THROUGH TWENTY FIVE WHICH I
JUST WENT OVER THEM. FROM A
HIGH LEVEL. SO AGAIN THIS IS
THIS THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE. IN
ADDITION TO VOTE ONLY ONCE WE
ADDRESSED EARLIER
. ONE THREE
TWENTY FIVE ONE THREE TWENTY
FIVE. THEY JUST GIVE ME ONE
MINUTE HERE THAT'S OKAY I
RESPECT THAT. TAKE. WE'LL PAUSE
FOR A MINUTE. ASSEMBLY.
YEAH.
MENDOCINO ONE OF THE- SOME OF
THE FEEDBACK THAT I'VE GOT FROM
MY DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS
AROUND EIGHTY EIGHT FUNDING-
ESPECIALLY AS WE HAD THIS HOLD
HARMLESS- WILL LAST IN THE
TWENTY. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR WE WERE LOOKING
AT THIS FOR TWENTY. ONE TWENTY
TWO- I THINK THAT MAYBE WE
COULD CONSIDER ADDRESSING YOU
KNOW EIGHTY EIGHT ALLOWING
DISTRICTS IF DISTRICTS TO HAVE
HIGHER EDA. IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEAR. TO-
REVISIT THERE ARE A HOLD
HARMLESS FUNDING FOR MAKING
SENSE HERE- IT'S A
CONSIDERATION THAT I THINK
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL AS SOME
DISTRICTS HAVE TAKEN ON MORE
STUDENTS AND WILL BE SERVING
MORE STUDENTS AND SHOULD BE
MADE WHOLE FINANCIALLY. YEAH
THAT'S THAT'S A POINT THAT WE-
HAVE NOTED YOU KNOW WE WERE
TRYING TO FOCUS ON THE ONES WHO
WENT THE OTHER DIRECTION OF
COURSE BUT SOME COMMUNITIES
HAVE GROWTH- I THINK THIS OF
THIS BUDGET ENABLES US TO. GET
THROUGH WORK ACT WITH THE
PANDEMIC. AND CERTAINLY WE
ALWAYS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REVISIT. THANK YOU SIR. I THINK
WE'RE WAITING MR IMAGINE IF
COMMENT YES SIR YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR- CONTINUED COMMITMENT
TO FUNDING OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IMPORTANT PRORAM. IS
FULLY FUNDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. YEAH THIS MISTER MEDINA
AND JUST AS YOU KNOW WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR- IF YOU THE
MEMBERS TO RECONCILE SOME OF
THE ITEMS TODAY- JUST WASN'T AS
THE PRIMARY FOR A LEGISLATION
WE WANT TO MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES
WORK AND THERE'S A COMPANION
BILL. WHICH WE- FULLY EMBRACED
THE ASSEMBLY. BUT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO HELP
IMPLEMENTED WITH THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AS WELL SO THIS I THINK
IS VERY VERY TIMELY. AND THANK
YOU FOR PUSHING THIS FOR ALL
THESE YEARS THANK YOU FOR NEVER
GIVING UP. YOUR JACK. OKAY SO
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND ON. ISSUE NUMBER HAT
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE WHICH
AGAIN. ARE ITEMS NUMBER. ONE
THROUGH. TWENTY TWO. AND- MR
GALLAGHER. SO YES I JUST TO
COLLECT SOME OF THE IN A LOT IN
HERE- AND THEY GET MOST BECAUSE-
CHANGES I THINK WE ARE
PROPOSING- IT WITH REGARD TO
STATE PRESCHOOL AND UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN- I DO
THINK WE NEED TO OBVIOUSLY WE
NEEDED WE NEED TO PUT IN HERE
THE RATE REFORM. PORTION I DO
THINK WE NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT. IT'S NICE OF THEM
PROPOSING TO VOTE AGAINST THIS
BUT WOULD YOU BE THINKING ABOUT.
TRANSITIONING I THINK FROM OUR
AMAR TO A MORE STANDARDIZED.
RATES BECAUSE IN THE LONG TERM
WE CAN GET TO AN UNEQUAL
POSITION- AGAIN DEPENDING ON
YOUR REGION- IF WE'RE BASING
IT. JUST ON RMR AND SO I MEAN
THAT'S ONE THING I'D FLAG IS
THAT WE MAY WANT SOME
FLEXIBILITY. INTO THE FUTURE TO
GO TO A MORE STANDARD- RATE
SYSTEM BUT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN
IMPROVEMENT ON WHAT WE'VE GOT.
RIGHT NOW- SO THAT WAS JUST ONE
THING I WANTED TO. MENTION ON
THIS- ON RE OPENING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT PORTION- IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO VOTE ON THAT SECTION
AT THIS POINT IN TIME BECAUSE
YOU REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY.
LANGUAGE CAN HAVE PLACEHOLDER
LANGUAGE. SO I WOULD HAVE CRIED
AS MAYBE A STAIN ON THAT ITEM
NUMBER- I THINK WE'VE
HIGHLIGHTED VERY CLEARLY THAT
THERE'S SOME PROBLEMS- MAYBE
THE MOST THE POSTER CHILD FOR
THIS IS SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED-
WHO. YOU'RE REALLY I THINK
ABUSE WHAT WE HAD PASSED
EARLIER IN THE YEAR. THE
OPENING FOR WHAT ONE DAY- OUT
OF THE YEAR AND- POSSIBLY-
COLLECTING FUNDS WERE MANY
OTHER SCHOOLS ACTUALLY DID
OPEN- AND. YOU KNOW AND IN SOME
WAYS IS KIND OF PUTS THEM AT A
DISADVANTAGE- MANY OF THOSE
SCHOOLS HAD TRANSPORTATION
COSTS. ALL KINDS OF OTHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH YOU KNOW MAKING
THE EFFORT THE REAL EFFORT TO
BE REACHED TO BE OPEN FOR KIDS
AND- HAVING SOME GREATER. YOU
KNOW- SAFEGUARDS ON WHAT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE I THINK WOULD
BE IMPORTANT- SO THAT'S. SHOP
WITH THE RIGHT ADAM I THINK I
WOULD HAVE STAINED OKAY- SO MR
GALLAGHER CAN CAN YOU GO BACK
AND JUST. SEE WHAT NUMBERS THEY
ARE I GUESS THAT WOULD BE
NUMBER NINE YEAH THAT WOULD
THAT BE RIGHT. K. TO OBTAINING
A NUMBER. NINE AND IN THE OTHER
THE OTHER ONES LIKE THE RATES
YOU WERE JUST PROVIDING SOME
COMMENTARY COMMENTS WHICH AGAIN
CURRENT AND THAT MAY WE TRIED
TO RUBIO RESERVE SOME KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY ON THAT IN THE
FUTURE- TO GO TO MORE
STANDARDIZED RATES.
NUMBER
FIFTEEN I WOULD BE IN A. AND
PRIMARILY BECAUSE AGAIN WE ARE
WE ARE EXCLUDING NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND AS
WE SAID I THINK THAT FOR
EXPANDING LEARNING LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES THEY SHOULD BE
AND INCLUDED.
AND THERE ARE NO
ON EIGHTEEN. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER WILL NOTE
THOSE ITEMS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VADAR STUDENTS- MENTIONED
ISSUES THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO.
HOW DOES NOT FOR YOUR YOUR
ABOUT. I'LL JUST BE AND STATE
ABSTAINING OR NOT VOTING ON
ITEM NUMBER NINE. AND WE'RE
NINE. OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION
SENATE YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ON THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE ISSUE- NUMBER
ONE. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM I
THINK MISTER LEE'S SECOND
PREMISE THAT HAVE BETTER SECOND
RANTS. AND WE NOTE ITEMS THAT
THE OTHER MEMBERS WILL BE
HOSTING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HI GALLAGHER. PLEASE
MEDINA FOR DONALD REYES.
VETERANS. OKAY. WE WERE NOT
ALMOST DONE. WITH THAT P. THREE
TWELVE PIECE HIGHER AT NEXT
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER TWO THIS IS
OUR EARLY EDUCATION PACKAGE FOR
THE ASSEMBLY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT- WE PUT A LOT OF WORK INTO.
AND WE DID EARLIER IN THE LAST
ITEM PROP NINETY EIGHT. ADOPT
THE MONUMENTAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN- UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN-
PROGRAM HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE WILL HAVE A RAMPING UP
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE FOR ALL KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. BUT WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT OVER AND OVER
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS PART OF
AN OVERALL PACKAGE SO NOT JUST
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WHICH
WE FULLY FUND THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT- BUT AS WELL AS MAKING
SURE WE TO STOP. OUR CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS IN THE PROVIDER RATES-
BECAUSE IT ONLY WORKS IF YOU
HAVE ALL THE PIECES OF PLUGGING
ALONG SO I KNOW THERE ARE LOTS
OF NUMBERS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HERE BUT I KIND OF WANT
TO PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE AS
FAR AS WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES SO. FIRST
FOR A LOT OF OUR ARE SUBSIDIZED
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA SOME
PEOPLE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECEIVE THEM- A LOT OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY IN HIGH COST AREAS
EXACT WHEN THE BAY AREA SOME
PARTS OF LA. THEY'RE PRICED OUT
THERE THERE'S THERE TO- FOR TWO
SO CALLED RICH TO GET THE FREE
PROGRAMS BUT THEY'RE WAY TOO
POOR TO PAY THE SOMETIMES
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH OR
MORE SOMETIMES A VERY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
EARLY EDUCATION SO.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
HAVING UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE
WILL BE A BIG BOON FOR MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE OTHER PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE INCLUDED WHICH IS
WHY WE EXPAND UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S. SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN CHILD CARE SLOTS
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES WE. KNOW
A HUNDRED THOUSAND. NEW CHILD
CARE. AND WE PROPOSE AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND.
THAT CHILD CARE SLOTS
ESSENTIALLY I'M GOING FROM
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
OR SO. THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SLOTS IN CALIFORNIA. TWO FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND A
SICK THAT SIGNIFICANT INCREASE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE ABOUT. FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES ON THE
WAITING LIST SO WITH THIS
ACTION WE WILL CUT THAT WAITING
LIST. AND HALF. AND THAT WOULD
REALLY CHANGE LIVES FOR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. BUT I'M
ONLY WORKING MOMS WHO ARE
TRYING TO. GET AHEAD GO TO WORK
GO TO SCHOOL SO THIS
ESSENTIALLY. WILL PUT OUR
VALUES- RIGHT- IN PEN AND
PENCIL RIGHT HERE TO OUR
ACTIONS TODAY. AND SECONDLY WE
HAVE THIS LONG OVERDUE- RATE
REFORM. WHICH IS YOU KNOW IT'S
SOUNDS LIKE REFORM GOVERNMENT
THING BUT IT'S REALLY. WAY MORE
THAN REFORMING RATES AS MR
GALLAGHER SAID IT MAKES
PROGRAMS- VIABLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FINANCIALLY VIABLE. HELPS
THEM PENCIL OUT MORE. BUT ALSO
ALLOWS THEM TO PAVE OUR
PROVIDERS ARE ARE WORKFORCE
THAT WE TREASURE. LIVING WAGES
SO YOU KNOW. SINCE SENT TO ME
TIMES ARE PROVIDERS- MOVE ON
FROM JOB TO JOB BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT PAID AN ADEQUATE WAGE THEY
CAN GO WORK AT A- FAST FOOD-
ESTABLISHMENT FOR MORE THAN
GET. AS A PRESCHOOL TEACHER SO.
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT IN TUNE WITH THEIR
VALUES SO THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO. TO BOOST UP THESE PROGRAMS
TO SERVE MORE. KIDS THROUGH THE
EXISTING- PRESCHOOL AND CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS RAMP
UP. WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH THE
NEW CHILD CARE SLOTS IN
ADDITION. WITH TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. WITH YOUR KIDS IN.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. THE BE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO USE THOSE OF THIS MONIE TO
SERVE KIDS THREE THREE. AND
WITH THESE INCREASED RATES WILL
BE ABLE TO SERVE. MORE
CALIFORNIA KIDS IN THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS ON SO THAT I THINK IS
A WIN FOR THE KIDS OF
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE. TWO YEARS
OR MORE OF QUALITY EARLY
EDUCATION BEFORE THEY ENTER
KINDERGARTEN REALLY ABLE TO
ADDRESS OUR KINDERGARTEN
READINESS GAP. BUT ALSO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T LEAVE ANYBODY
BEHIND. TO MAKE SURE THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS ARE THRIVING
AND THEY PAY THEIR WORK FORCE A
LIVING WAGES. ON THE THIRD
ISSUE HERE IS THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PRESCHOOL
FACILITIES GRANTS. I WILL BE
AMENDING THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
VERY REVISED PROPOSAL AND
FUNDING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME- TO EXPAND-
THOSE FACILITIES AND EXPAND
CAPACITY- WE ALSO RESTORE. IS
THOUGHT I NEVER FOR THE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES- BLOCK GRANT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- NUMBER FIVE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A CONCERN WITH
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
UNIVERSAL TKA. WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH OUR EXISTING
WORKFORCE. AND AND YOU KNOW WE
THINK IT'S THERE'S NOT GOING TO
BE IN- ANYTHING TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THERE WILL BE MORE JOBS
AVAILABLE. IN EARLY EDUCATION
WITH TEEKAY NOW HAVING TO HIRE
MORE- CREDENTIAL TEEKAY
TEACHERS AS WELL AS PART
PROFESSIONALS IN THE CLASSROOM.
WE'RE GOING TO BE NEEDING MORE
INDIVIDUALS SEARCH SERVING. THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR A
THREE'S POTENTIALLY FORCING
FAMILIES WHO WANT TO STAY IN
STATE PRESCHOOL. AS WELL AS
INFANTS AND TODDLERS SO THIS
WILL HELP HELP US BUILD THAT.
THE NUMBER OF- PROFESSIONALS IN
THE STATE. THROUGH- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND AGAIN WITH THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES PAY THEM
PROPER. WAGES AND- IT NUMBER SO
WITH TO HUNDRED- ITEM NUMBER
SIX EXCUSE ME PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
FEDERAL. FUNDS FOR EXPANDED
LICENSING CHILD CARE CAPACITY.
THIS IS THE BILL BACK CHILD
CARE. AND THEN AND ISSUED
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS RAY S.
MENTIONED EARLIER WE PROVIDE
ONE TIME MONEY TO- CAP FAMILY
TOO I'M SORRY TO WAY FAMILY
FEES. THREE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WHICH HAS BEEN A PRIORITY OF
THE ASSEMBLY AS WELL AS A DOT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. TO CAP FAMILY FEES OF
7% AFTER TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
I'VE NEVER EIGHT- WE WOULD-
THIS IS NOT THE QUESTION. YES
THIS IS VERY BAD. OKAY HAVE I
HAD AN EIGHT THIS IS THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED
AGREEMENT- THIS IS A PIECE OF
THE AGREEMENT ARE STILL AT WORK
TO BE DONE WITH OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT THIS WOULD RATIFY A PIECE
OF THAT AGREEMENT HAS BEEN
REACHED RELATED TO PANDEMIC
RELIEF INCLUDING STIPENDS
CLOSURE DAYS HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONS MENTAL HEALTH
RECRUITMENT AND AGAIN FAMILY
FEES. I REMEMBER NINE CHILD
NUTRITION WE RESTORE ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR- FEDERAL MAIL FUNDS AS WELL
AS THE CHILD AN ADULT MEAL.
PROGRAM WE ALLOCATE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE MY CHILD CARE
PLAN .ORG. THE SOCIAL SERVICES-
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS WE
PROVIDE TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ON GOING FEDERAL FUNDS TO
SUPPORT OUR RESEARCH RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL AGENCIES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE ADMINISTERING
PROBABLY THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM. AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE ARE
ADOPTING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET ON
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY CHILD CARE
PILOT PROGRAM TO JULY. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND AS NOTED
EARLIER. THIS SOUNDS LIKE A
LAUNDRY LIST OF ISSUES BUT THIS
IS CERTAINLY A PACKAGE THAT- WE
HAVE BEEN DREAMING AND SCHEMING
ABOUT FOR MANY YEARS SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT AT ALL WE'RE ALL
VERY VERY PROUD OF I KNOW THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT COMES. DOWN
FROM THE SPEAKER AS WELL OUR
VALUES ARE ABOUT INVESTING IN
OUR FUTURE AND NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT THAN OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS. AS YOU SAID A FEELING
OR VIA THERE IS A FEW MONTHS
AGO LITTLEST LEARNERS SO I WITH
THAT DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FOR OUR EARLY EDUCATION
PACKAGE. MOVED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE SECOND BY SELLING
OVER MY INTEREST. ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THESE ITEMS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER. YEAH
AGAIN I WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT
THE MINUTE AGAIN SUPPORTIVE OF
THE EXPANSION OF SLOTS- BUT THE
RMR YOU KNOW WE'VE IN OURSELVES
OR FLEXIBILITY GET TO A
STANDARDIZED RATE WHICH I THINK
ULTIMATELY WOULD BE- THE BETTER.
MORE SOUND POSITION FOR US- IN
THE LONG TERM I WHICH COULD BE
PHASED IN OVER TIME MIA NEW
RATE STRUCTURE COULD BE PHASED
IN OVER MULTIPLE YEARS- ON THE-
I HAD A NUMBER TO. I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF
THE T. K. EXPANSION- WE- YEAH.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
FUNDING LIKE DIRECTED TOWARDS
SHE K. EXPANSION INTO SO. WOULD
LIKE TO SEE LIKE MORE MONIES
DIRECTED TOWARDS T. K.
EXPANSION SINCE THAT'S- THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED MORE
FACILITIES FOR THAT I MEAN I
THINK A LOT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE SAYING. THAT IF WE EXPAND
T. K. WE'RE GONNA NEED TO ALSO.
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR EXPANDING
FACILITIES. AND I'VE ALSO WOULD
NOTE ON SOME OF THESE AT LEAST
ON THE- WE COULD USE OUR
PROVIDES INSTEAD A GENERAL FUND
FOR SOME OF THESE FACILITIES-
COSTS. AS THE ITEM EIGHT I
REALIZE THAT THIS IS ALREADY
BEEN NEGOTIATED. I THINK THERE
ARE ISSUES WITH THE HOLD
HARMLESS POLICY- IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW ENSURING THAT WE HAVE.
WORKFORCE. BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN NEGOTIATED WE'RE
OBLIGATED. TO PHIL THAT
CONTRACT.
WHEN THE SO THOSE
WOULD BE MY COMMENTS JUST ON
THIS PACKAGE AS A WHOLE- BUT
OVERALL I BELIEVE IT IS A
SUPPORTABLE PACKAGE AND AS HE
SAID THAT- MUCH NEEDED
IMPROVEMENT. IN INVESTMENT. IN
THIS AREA- EARLY CARE AND-
CHILD CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION
WHICH WE KNOW IS IMPORTANT TO
THE FUTURE OF OUR OF OUR
CHILDREN SO- PRECIADO DATA
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I'LL AND
WITH THAT. OKAY THANK YOU.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SLIMMER
VIRUS. I JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT-
I AM. SO EXCITED ABOUT THIS
EXPANSION INTO QUE AND
INVESTMENT AND CHILD CARE AND
EARLY LEARNING. ON AT A TIME
WHERE WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
THIS FOR YEARS IF NOT DECADES.
AND YOU KNOW IF ANYTHING YOU
KNOW I TALK A LOT ABOUT MY FOUR
YEAR OLD AND- YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY SPEND THE AT THE ONSET OF
THIS PANDEMIC. MY DAUGHTER WAS.
THREE- ARE JUST TURNED THREE
ACTUALLY SHE HAD HER THIRD
BIRTHDAY V. AS IN PARTY. AND
THE CHILD THE WHAT HAPPENS IN
TRANSPIRES FROM THREE TO FOUR
IS JUST AMAZING TO SEE A CHILD
GROW AND UNDERSTAND THEIR WORLD
AND CONCEPTS. AND FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY. AND SHE TURNED FOR
THIS PAST APRIL. AND I HAD THIS
REALIZATION THAT OUR FOUR YEAR
OLDS ARE LOOKING AT THIS WORLD.
AND LOOKING AT THEIR WORLD AND
THEY THINK IT'S A WORLD FULL OF
MASS AND NOT BEING ABLE TO COME
IN CONTACT WITH PEOPLE AND
HAVING TO SIT SIX FEET AWAY.
FROM OTHER CHILDREN THEIR VIEW
OF OUR WORLD IS SO. DIFFERENT
AND IT'S KIND OF SAD- IT'S SAD
WHEN I'M OUTSIDE NOW AND MY
DAUGHTER DOESN'T WANT TO TAKE
OFF HER MASK EVEN THOUGH IT'S
JUST MOMMY. AND HER AND THIS IS
COMING AT A TIME WHERE THESE
FOUNDATIONAL YEARS ARE GOING TO
BE REALLY HARD TO GET BACK. SO
TO SEE THIS EXPANSION NOW. AND
THE WORLD THAT IT IS GOING TO
CHANGE FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS AND
THREE GIRLS. AND TWO YEAR OLDS
AND ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. I'M
JUST REALLY PROUD THAT WE'RE
INVESTING THE WAY THAT WE ARE.
THINKING OF. THANK YOU AND-
BEFORE WE TAKE A VOTE ON THIS I
JUST WANT TO SAY YOU KNOW THAT
THEIR- ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THIS SPACE IN EARLY EDUCATION
WHETHER THEY'RE- A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER AT THE CENTER BASED
PROGRAM. STATE PRESCHOOL
CONTRACTOR. FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES THAT ALLEY A OR T. K.
PROVIDERS. WHO ARE EXCITED THAT
FRANKLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS ISSUE. THAT'S I MEAN HALF
THE BATTLES WERE TALKING ABOUT
HOW TO SPEND. BILLIONS IN NEW
MONEY. FOR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS- THERE'S SURE THERE'S
GOING TO BE SENT THANKS IN
SOME. GIVEN TAKE AS FAR AS HOW
WE IMPLEMENT IN DO THIS- BUT
THAT'S NOT THE BALLOT. IN PRIOR
YEARS WE HAD A FIGHT JUST TO
PUT THIS ISSUE. ON THE AGENDA.
AN HOUR ON THE TABLE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THE MOVING
PIECES FIT TOGETHER AND SO. I
JUST WANTED TO REASSURE THAT-
HI. AS FAR AS THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR OF THE
THAT THE SIGNATURE BILL. ON A
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
ALONG WITH THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL IN THE SENATE SIMILARLY
MOUNTED ON IMPLEMENTATION SB
FIFTY ARE COMMITTED TO MAKE
SURE WE DO THIS RIGHT. AND WE
LEAVE NO ONE BEHIND. BECAUSE IF
WE IF WE DO THIS RIGHT NOT
CONVINCED THAT WE CAN AND HAVE
YOU KNOW AS I'VE SAID ALL
ALONG. A WIN WIN WIN. THIS IS
TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR FAMILY
THIS WILL CHANGE LIVES. IF YOU
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES OF THE
DAY THEY WERE TRYING TO TACKLE.
YOU KNOW THE STUBBORN- HAD SHE
BEEN GAP IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WELL IT DOESN'T START IN.
FOURTH GRADE OR FIFTH GRADE IN
HIGH SCHOOL YOU TEACH MISTER
O'DONNELL IT STARTS AND WHEN
KIDS ENTER SCHOOL AND IN IN
KINDERGARTEN SO. EARLY
EDUCATION IS REALLY ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY GAPS OF THIS HAS A
CHANCE TO AND IT WILL- CHANGE
LIVES AND WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE VALUE AND RESPECT ARE.
EASY PROFESSIONALS ALONG THE
WAY- CERTAINLY THERE ARE GOING
TO BE- SOME. PAINS MAKING WORK
BUT- WE YOU HAVE OUR COMMITMENT
THAT WE WILL WORK HAND IN HAND.
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST. OF CALIFORNIANS
NOT SO WITH THAT. WE HAVE A
MOTION THE SECOND LISTS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE ASSEMBLY
EARLY EDUCATION. PACKAGE
MCCARTY HI. GALLAGHER LEE
MEDINA BUT DONALD. REYES
BALLADARES. OKAY THAT ITEM
PASSES WE'RE GOING TO- TAKE A
ONE OR TWO MINUTE BREAK WHILE
WE TRANSITION TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION PACKAGE THIS
CONCLUDES THE EARLY AD AND K.
TWELVE SOMEONE PROVIDE OUR- AND
I THINK THERE WAS SOME
CONFUSION ON YEAH- AND I JUST
WANTED TO. CLARIFY SOME VOTES
YEP OF COURSE. SO ON OUR FIRST
ITEMS OUR FIRST ISSUE THIS IS
OKAY- ADAM. NINE I IN NOT
VOTING VOTERS ITEM FORTY TWO NO.
I AM SEVENTY SIX. NOT VOTING.
ADAM EIGHTY FOUR NOT VOTING.
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX NO.
ADAM ONE THIRTY NOT VOTING ADAM
ONE THIRTY ONE NOT LOOKING.
THANK YOU FOR. OKAY THANK YOU
ROAD TAKE A BREAK FOR A COUPLE
MINUTES WHILE WE MOVED TO MR
GALLAGHER THE CHANGES- ON THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT ITEM BY ALSO
WANTED TO BE NO ONE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO. OKAY GOT IT THANK
YOU.
ARE WAITING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES TO YOU WANT TO ADD ON AND
VOTE ON THE ITEMS THAT YOU
MISSED. SUMMARY LARA WAITING
YOU WANT TO ADD ON AND WILL
FOCUS ON SO WHAT'S WE MISSED
YOUR VOTE ON THE EARLY
EDUCATION PACKAGE. HI RES I.
AND THEN AS WELL AS- WE MISSED
YOU FOR THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE HI REYES AYE AND- THANK.
YEAH THE SENATE I DIDN'T
REALIZE. PRESIDENT. NO. ONE IT
WAS A- SHE WASN'T. I STARTED.
YOU SEE. ONE HE NEVER CALLED.
OKAY. OKAY I WILL GIVE. YEAH
YEAH YOUR BEST. YEAH. THEY GET
IN AN AREA WHERE. BUT AS YOU
CAN- YEAH. YEAH I THINK THAT.
YEAH.
OKAY WE WILL GET BACK-
ADDED HERE WE HAVE THE HIGHER
ED CLOSE OUT SECTION FOR THE
BUDGET TODAY FOR THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE AT TODAY WERE GONNA CAST-
VOTES ON THE MAJORITY OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION BUDGET I WILL
NOTE THAT THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE ARE STILL WORKING
TOWARDS- SOME MAJOR PIECES OF
HIGHER EDUCATION- AGREEMENT
THAT SUPPORTS OUR MUTUAL
PRIORITIES FOR EACH HOUSE THE
ISSUES OF ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY ARE PARAMOUNT
WE'RE STILL IN DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT CRITICAL ISSUES SUCH AS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. INCREASING
CAPACITY AT UC AND CSU AS WELL
AS CAL GRANT IN MIDDLE CAP
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP EXPANSION I
WOULD HOPE TO HAVE THESE AGREED
UPON SOON WE WON'T BE PUTTING
ON THIS TODAY BUT THE FULL-
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND THE FULL
ASSEMBLY WILL BE VOTING ON
THESE NEXT WEEK. OVERALL THE-
OVER PROVIDING TODAY IS A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
EXPANSION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
ACCESS- WE FOCUS THE PAST YEAR
AND GETTING THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC I THINK WE'VE- WE'VE
MOSTLY BEEN ABLE TO- TO- TO GET
PAST THIS- WE STILL WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN FOCUS ON. IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION- THE ISSUES
OF STUDENT BASIC NEED EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BECAME PARAMOUNT
DURING THIS- CURVE IN NINETEEN
CRISIS FOR OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS- SOME ISSUES WERE WERE
FAR MORE SO THAN OTHERS AS FAR
AS THE IMPACT FOR WE ARE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FELT THE
BRUNT MORE THAN A UC'S AS FAR
AS- A LOSS. OF STUDENT
ENROLLMENT WE DO FOCUS ON
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR ALL
SEGMENTS TO BOUNCE BACK
PROVIDE. ADEQUATE COLON FOR
COLLEGES SPECIAL OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND EXPAND- PROVEN
PROGRAMS LIKE MESA PLANT DAY
AMMO JIM AS WELL AS- THE RISING
SCHOLARS PROGRAM. AS FAR AS
SEVERAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSALS WE DO REJECT
SEVERAL OF THESE PROPOSALS SOME
MAY HAVE VALID GOALS BUT WE
FELT THAT SUPPORTING OUR
INSTITUTIONS TODAY. IN
STUDENTS. ARE THE PRIORITY
VERSUS- CREATING SOME NEW
PROGRAMS THAT MAY BE DIFFICULT
TO IMPLEMENT QUICKLY I WE KNOW
WE KNOW THAT STUDENTS AND
CAMPUSES NEED RESOURCES NOW. SO
WE'RE OPTING FOR EXPANDING OUR
UNDER RESOURCE PROGRAMS TODAY-
AGAIN FINALLY R. TOPPERS I'M IN
THE SAME THERE IS AN ACCESS
CRISIS TO HIGHER EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA- WE THINK THAT THE
UC AND CSU. ALLOCATIONS SHOULD
SUPPORT ENROLLMENT GROWTH. IT'S
CERTAINLY A TOP PRIORITY WE
HEAR ABOUT ALL THE TIME IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE TALK ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION. ACCESS TO OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES- YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEATEN TO DEATH THE
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT ISSUE WE
WANT THERE'S NO BUDGET PROPOSAL
NOT HERE TODAY I KNOW. THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE ARE STILL
TALKING ABOUT THAT BUT THAT
ISSUE REMAINS THE SAME WE WANT
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO ART UC
CAMPUSES ESPECIALLY OUR
FLAGSHIP CAMPUSES. AB WOULD
RELATED TO FINANCIAL AID AND
CAL GRANT. WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR
CALIFORNIA. IN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS REMAIN
SHUT OUT OF THE PROGRAM. AND AS
WELL AS MANY STUDENTS RECEIVE.
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT FOR. FOR
FOR FINANCIAL AID THROUGH
TUITION BUT DON'T ALWAYS COVER.
THE TRUE COST OF TUITION WHICH
FOCUSES ON HOUSING IN TUITION.
I MEAN HOUSING AND FOOD AND
BOOKS. SO WITH THAT OVER I
THINK WE HAVE A EVER. HIGH YOU
PACK. WE'LL START WITH THEM A
VOTE ONLY ITEMS LIKE WE DIDN'T
PROP NINETY EIGHT AND EARLY
EDUCATION. AND THEN GET TO OUR-
OUR MAJOR PACKAGES FROM
LEGISLATURE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
FOR UC'S YOU. COMMUNICATE ALL
AGES STUDENT COMMISSION
LIBRARY. AS WELL AS THE
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM IN THE
SCHOOL FINANCE OF THIRTY OTHER
WITH THAT BEFORE A. B. BEGIN-
WE HAVE COMMENTS FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK OF THE STAFF. CHAIR
AND MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE I I'VE I THINK THIS
IS A BUDGET. FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT WE CAN ALL BE
PROUD OF ITS STRONG AND SOLID-
FOR ALL THREE SEGMENTS. OF A
HIGHER EDUCATION- I DO HAVE. A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS- ECHO THE
CHAIR DESIRE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR AND OUR
COLLEAGUES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MODERNIZE- THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS- I ALSO WANT TO SEE.
RESTORATION TO FUNDING OF THE
CAMPUS LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM- CSU AND UC I THANK YOU
EACH OF THOSE SYSTEMS WOULD
HAVE JUST. THE SAME. ACROSS THE
SYSTEMS WOULD MAKE IT MUCH
EASIER FOR STUDENTS. AND THEN I
JUST WANT TO- CONTINUE TO- BE
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE-
AND- ELIMINATING CALIBRATE
RECOGNIZING THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CAN DO THE SAME JOB.
REMOTE MUCH LESS AND BE MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU WITH THAT.
WE WILL HAVE A- AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GO THROUGH THE VOTE ONLY
ITEMS THESE ARE ESSENTIALLY ON
THE AGENDA PAGES. THREE THREE
TWELVE THESE ARE ITEMS THAT WE
HEARD DURING- THE SPRING AS FAR
AS THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSALS AS WELL AS
SOME NAY REVISED PROPOSALS-
THESE ARE THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS
THESE ARE TWENTY TWO- ISSUES
RELATED TO THE CALIPHATE
LIBRARY THE UC HASTINGS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STATE
COMMISSION. AND THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION ON THE AGENDA THESE
ARE AGAIN PAGES ONE THROUGH
TWELVE ISSUES. ONE THREE TWENTY
TWO. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
VOTE ONLY ITEMS. MR LEE MR LEE-
LIVES IN THE SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIGHT YES TO HAVE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OR NEED
TO REMOVE SOME OF THESE ITEMS
FOR ABOUT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU GET.
HOWEVER GALLAGHER. YES GOING
THROUGH AGAIN ITEMS- THROUGH
PAGE TWELVE RIGHT CORRECT- SO I
WOULD DO IN THE ISSUE NUMBER
SIX. I DID WANT TO BE A NO ON
THE ART COLLECTION DISASTER
PREP. OKAY AND THEN. AS YOU
NUMBER EIGHT NO ISSUE NUMBER
NINE NO. ISSUES TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN-
THAT'S ALL I HAVE
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VIDAK: YEAH YOU MIGHT. SO THAT.
THANK YOU. ON ISSUE. NUMBER.
EIGHT I'M SORRY NATIONAL ASIAN
NUMBER NINE NO. ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE. NO. FISHING NUMBER
THIRTEEN NO. THAT'S IT THANK
YOU. OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ON
THOSE ITEMS WITH THE-
ADJUSTMENTS FIRST
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GALLAGHER
INVITED OURS. IS CALDERON
MCCARTY HI GALLAGHER. LEE
MEDINA. BUT DONALD PRESS.
BETTER. OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE ASSEMBLY. PACKAGE FOR
THE- THE UC THIS IS AGAIN WE'RE
STILL HOLDING OUT SOME- ACTION
ITEMS RELATED TO- ENROLLMENT
AND THEN ACCESS EXPANSION FOR-
OFF CAMPUS CENTERS AS WELL AS
CAMPUS AS WELL THANK YOU SEE
CAMPUS- AND ALSO HOUSING
PROPOSALS. BUT BUT WITH THAT WE
HAVE THE UC PACKAGE REBUTTING A
RIGHT NOW WHICH PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES STUDENT
EMERGENCY AID AND MAKING SUMMER
FINANCIAL AID PERMANENT WHICH
IS IMPORTANT TO HELP US WITH
OUR GRADUATION RATES WE ARE
REJECTING SEVERAL PROPOSALS
INCLUDING THE PROPOSED LEARNING
ALIGN EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS.
ESTATE WORK STUDY IS AN
INTERESTING IDEA BUT THIS
PROGRAM HAS A COMPLICATED IN
DOWN THE STRUCTURE AND THEIR
QUESTIONS FALLS HOUSE WITH
INTERACTIVE PRIVATE COMPANIES.
WE ARE ALSO REJECTING FOLDING
THE UNIVERSITY OF THE PRESIDENT
BUDGET INTO THE MAIN YOU SEE
BUDGET. LISTEN NO RATIONALE FOR
THIS CHANGE AS WELL AS THE-
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR FOR YEARS AGO REMAINS
STRONG- AND WE ARE TAKING MONEY
AWAY FROM THE PROPOSED PROPOSAL
FOR ANIMAL SHELTERS AND USING
IT TO FIND. STUDENT ACADEMIC
OUTREACH PROGRAMS TO EXPAND YOU
SEE ACCESS FOR UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA- COMMUTE
COLLAR WHICH DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WHICH
ALWAYS NEED A FUNDING- FOR
THESE PROGRAMS- AGAIN WOULD WE
REMAIN A CONVERSATION WITH THE
SENATE. ABOUT SOME OF OUR BIG
PRIORITIES- WE DO KNOW THAT- WE
NEED TO ENROLL AN AD TEN
THOUSAND MORE UC STUDENTS THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. TO MEET OUR
OUR DEMANDS FOR MORE GRADUATES
TO FILL THE JOBS OF TODAY AND
TOMORROW AT PBS C. HAS YOU KNOW
HAS A BACHELOR'S DEGREE-
CALCULATOR AS TAX THAT WILL
WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNI. NEED TO RAMP UP THE
UC ENROLLMENT GROWTH WHICH WERE
PLANNING ON DOING THROUGH-
ENROLLMENT GROWTH TARGETS IN
THE UC. AS WELL AS LOOKING AT
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT AT UC AS
WELL AS LOOK AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TO EXPAND OUR
FOOTPRINT. AT SOME OFF CAMPUS
CENTERS TWO OF WHICH WE THINK
ARE VERY PROMISING ARE THE
PROPOSAL IN BERKELEY WITH-
KNOWS COLLEGE AS WELL AS- A UC
DAVIS EXPAND OUR FOOTPRINT
HERE. IN SACRAMENTO THE CAPITAL
CITY- WE ALSO THINK THAT WE CAN
HELP THIS HELP YOU SEE STUFF
POP IN. THE ROLE MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS BY
PROVIDING MORE RESOURCES TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING ON CAMPUSES. WITH THAT
THAT IS THE UC PACKAGE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE SEE-
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIGHT YES IN A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE- WE HAVE
QUESTION FROM SOME REVISED
TARIFFS MR THE- HE WAS THE
FORMER. A GOVERNMENT MANDATE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. NOTHING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. OKAY
WE'RE GOOD DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
ANNOUNCER. EXACTLY. THE. TWELVE
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE. OKAY. OKAY
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND FOR THE UC- BUDGET
PACKAGE WHICH IS ON PAGE
FOURTEEN OF THE AGENDA THESE
ARE IS ISSUE NUMBER ONE IN THE
OF ITEMS NUMBER ONE THREE
NINETEEN WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY HI GALLAGHER. WE MEDINA
BUT DONALD REYES. LATER. OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT IS THE CSU
PACKAGE ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE
PACKAGE WERE VOTING ON TODAY
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING
HIGHLIGHTS FUNDING FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES STUDENT
BURN C. H. AND MAKING THIS
SUMMER FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
PERMANENT AGAIN SIGNIFICANTLY
HELPS THE CSU ADDRESS THEY GET
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE TO
HELP GRADUATES GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS HELP THEM AND HELP THEM
HAVE LESS STUDENT DEBT. AND
ALSO ALLOW US TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO CS- YOU WE ALSO- SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AT THE
STANISLAUS STATE- STOCKTON
CENTER. LIKE I MENTIONED IT
WITH THE UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA
WE'RE STILL IN DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT CSU- THEIR MAIN ITEMS
WE'D LIKE TO ADD A NEW
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AT THE CSU TO
ALLOW MORE CALIFORNIANS TO
ENROLL. AT THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUS CSU SYSTEM THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS TO AGAIN MEET THE- DAY
EMPLOYMENT DEMANDS OF OUR STATE
OUR EMPLOYERS TODAY AND
TOMORROW- IN LINE WITH THE PPO
SEE TARGETS WHERE WE SAY WE
NEED TO ADD FIFTEEN THOUSAND
MORE. GRADUATES OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS- WE HOPE TO ALSO
SUPPORT EXPANSION OF BOTH- OFF
CAMPUS CENTERS LIKE YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER YOU SEE. AS
WELL AS- HELP EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS
TO ENROLL AT OUR MOST IN DEMAND
CAMPUSES. I WITH THAT DO WE
HAVE A PROMOTION ON THE CSU
BUDGET PACKAGE. MY MISTER
DONALD SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEE DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THE CSU BUDGET
PACKAGE. AGAIN THIS IS ON THE
AGENDA PAGE SIXTEEN. ITEMS ONE
THROUGH. TWELVE SEEING NONE
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MCCARTY I GALLAGHER. LEE
MEDINA FOR DONALD BREATH FIVE
HOURS. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
THE GALLAGHER I LISTEN NUMBER
THREE THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- BUDGET PACKAGE THIS
IS ART THIS IS PAGE SEVENTEEN
ON THE AGENDA THIS IS THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS PACKAGE WHICH IS
A JOINT. ASSEMBLY SENATE
AGREEMENT- THINK THE PACKAGE
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND ARE OVER
ONE HUNDRED COLLEGES IN SEVERAL
KEY WAYS WE HEARD FROM OUR
COLLEGES LOUD AND CLEAR THIS
SPRING AS FAR AS THE INADEQUATE
COLON. WE PROVIDE THE SAME COLA
THAT WE GIVE TO OUR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS WHICH IS THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY ONE MILLION IN NEW
ON GOING FUNDING. WE FIND MANY
STUDENT SUPPORT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE MO JO A PLANT DAY
MAY SET IN E. O. PS AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER- WE ALSO
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
FOR PART TIME FACULTY. AND
PROVIDE ENOUGH FUNDING FOR THE
SYSTEM TO ADD AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND NEW FULL TIME FACULTY-
WE SUPPORT A MAJOR EXPANSION OF
BASIC NEEDS SERVICES. THIRTY
MILLION ON GOING TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY CAMPUS HAS A BASIC NEED
CENTER I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN FOR AUTHORING
LEGISLATION AND PUSHING US
FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE- WE ALSO
PROVIDE- A HUNDRED- MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL BASIC NEEDS
FUNDING. AS WELL AS A HUNDRED
FIFTY- MILLION EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID. I WE AGREE WITH
THE SENATE. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA I HEARD HERE NOTED THAT
IT'S TIME TO END THE
EXPERIMENTS OF THE CALIBRATE A
COLLEGE WE KNOW THAT DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BECAME EXPERTS
UNFORTUNATELY AN ONLINE
DISTANCE LEARNING AND THEY CAN
BE BETTER USED TO HELP OUR OUR
WORKERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND CREATE A STRONGER
WORKFORCE. I WE DO CREATE THE
PROGRAM OF RISING SCHOLARS TO
HELP JUST TO SUPPORT JUSTICE
INVOLVED STUDENTS IF YOU WON'T
REALLY WANT TO DEAL WITH.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
DEAL WITH- MAKING SURE WE DON'T
HAVE- MORE INDIVIDUALS GOING
THROUGH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. WITH RECIDIVISM WE NEED
TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS LIKE THESE
I THINK THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR BEING. A CHAMPION
SUPPORTING THIS SPONSOR MRS
WELL. AS THE WITH THAT THOSE
ARE THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PACKAGE. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION MOTION BY SOME
REMEMBER RANSACK BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PACKAGE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO THANK YOU ALSO
FOR THIS THE COLA INCREASE OF
THE FIVE POINT OH SEVEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FOURTEEN
pPROTECTIONS OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. THE ONE THING THAT
I THINK IS MISSING AND
SOMETHING FOR THE FUTURE TO
LOOK AT IS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
WITH MANY HOMELESS STUDENTS I
THINK FOR BILLION DOLLAR ASK
HAS BEEN REQUESTED IN THE PAST
AND I HOPE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FIND SOME TIME TO DO THAT EVEN
IN SEPTEMBER DINO VALLEY
COLLEGE JUST AS AN EXAMPLE WE
HAVE FOUR HUNDRED. UNOFFICIAL
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND THIS
HOUSING IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT PROVIDED
FOR COMMUTE CALLED STUDENTS. AT
ANY LEVEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE BEFORE WE DO THAT BUT
I WILL NOTE THAT WITH THE FOR
THE FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
PLACEHOLDER FOR HOUSING WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON THAT AND
POTENTIALLY COME BACK WITH A
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD INCLUDE
HOUSING FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- SYSTEM AS WELL SO
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT OVER YET
I WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
AFFECT A MISTER GALLAGHER. IS
NOW TIME TO. IDENTIFIES CERTAIN
PORTIONS YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION
A SECOND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PACKAGE IF YOU WANT TO TAKE
SOME OF THOSE OFF AS FAR AS
YOUR YOUR VOTES PLEASE LET US
KNOW NOW. YEAH WITHIN THAT
PACKAGES- NO ON ITEM.
EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWO. IN. TWENTY OKAY.
THANK YOU. OKAY WITH THAT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MCCARTY HI
GALLAGHER. LEE MEDINA DONALD
RALPH PIETERS. OKAY THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION BUDGET
PACKAGE THIS IS PAGE TWENTY TWO
ON THE AGENDA. WE ALSO REMAIN
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SENATE
ABOUT CAL GRANT EXPANSION AS
WELL AS BOOSTING. ACCESS TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. THIS
IS ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES IN
HIGHER EDUCATION THEY KNOW
SOMEONE MEMBER MEDINA HIGHER
CHAIRS BEEN HAS BEEN LEADING-
WE HAD A GROW BEST HEARING ON
THIS EARLIER THIS YEAR. WE KNOW
WE HAVE A NDS CAL GRANT SYSTEM
BUT IT'S OUTDATED AND IT SHUTS
THE DOOR AND TOO MANY NEEDY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. AS WELL AS
WITH THE STATE'S HIGH COST OF
LIVING. AT FINANCIAL AID IS NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED AND SO
THEY'LL BE MORE TO COME ON THIS
ISSUE NEXT WEEK. HOWEVER THE
PACKAGE TODAY INCLUDES
APPROVING THE PROPOSAL TO
REQUIRE HIGH SCHOOLS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL STUDENTS FILL OUT. THE
FACTS THAT- DREAM ACT
APPLICATION THANK YOU SO MEMBER
RAY S. AND WE'LL PUT- MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALIGN WITH- THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S BILL ON THIS
MEASURE TO THE STUDENTS CAN
EASILY OPT OUT IF THEY WANT. TO
AND ARE NOT PUNISHED IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO FILL THEM OUT
ISSUE THAT MR O'DONNELL BROUGHT
UP IN SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS- WE
ALSO WANT TO. ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE MONEY. FOR OUR FOSER
YOUTH SO WE PROVIDE TWENTY
MILLION ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. RECEIVED A
FULL SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR ACCESS
AWARD- WE ALSO PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER PROGRAM WHICH
WILL PROVIDE FINANCIAL AID TO
STUDENTS SEEKING A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL. THIS IS A KEY
EFFORT IN ADDRESSING. OUR
TEACHER SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
ALONG WITH OUR TEACHER PACKAGE
IN A POP NINETY EIGHT PLEASE. I
WITH THAT- DOWE HAVE A MOTION
A SECOND ON THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION PACKAGE THE MOVE BY
SOME REMEMBER LEE. SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN RACE. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR ANY OTHER
NOTIFICATIONS. THING NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MCCARTY
HI GALLAGHER. WE MEDINA FOR
DONALD. BREATH WHETHER. OKAY
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THIS IS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURER
SCHOLAR SHARED BOARDS LEAD TO
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS THIS
IS ISSUE NUMBER FIVE ON AGENDA
PAGE TWENTY THREE. WE- WE HAVE
AN EGG WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT TO
MODIFY THE GOVERNOR'S
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL A COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WE STILL THINK
THIS IS A FABULOUS IDEA THANK
GOD SOMEBODY NUMBER NAZARIAN
FOR PUSHING THIS FOR THE PAST
FEW YEARS AND ALLOWING US TO
REALLY. STEP IT UP IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET WE ARE WE ARE
SHRINKING THE- OF THE
ALLOCATION FROM ROUGHLY TWO
BILLION- TWO ONE BILLION AND TO
FIND EXISTING CAL KIDS PROGRAM
AND WE WILL PROVIDE FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME FOR LOCAL
COLLEGE SAVINGS PROGRAM AS WELL
AS THE ON GOING A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION TO FIND
ANNUALLY- KIDS IN THE CAL KIDS
PROGRAM TO HELP COLLEGE SAVINGS
TO MAKE SURE COLLEGES MORE
ATTAINABLE FOR. ALL EVERYBODY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE BY SOMEONE
A REYES SECOND MY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LEAVE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS THING NINE HE'S
KALRA. MCCARTY HI GALLAGHER.
LEE MEDINA MADONNA. REYES BUT
OUR. OKAY LAST ISSUE ISSUE
NUMBER SIX IS THAT THE SCHOOL
FINANCE AUTHORITY LATEST
STUDENT HOUSING- THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES-
PROPOSES RESOURCES FROM THE
MARY VICE FOR STUDENT HOUSING.
OKAY GOTCHA GOTCHA SO THERE'S
IT'S AFFORDABLE IN OUR PROPOSAL
TO BILLION THIS YEAR AND TWO
BILLION FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR-
WE AGAIN WE ARE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE SENATE ON- MODIFYING
THIS PROPOSAL- TODAY WE ARE
REJECTING THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSAL- AND WE WILL CERTAINLY
COME BACK WITH THIS ISSUE AND
HOPEFULLY I REVISIT THIS AND
FOR COMMITTEE- IN THE COMING
DAYS. SO WITH THAT WE ARE
HAVING A RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY
REVISED PROPOSAL MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- REYES SECOND
MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LEE
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS OR
COMMENTS. SAYING NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MCCARTY HI
GALLAGHER. LEE MEDINA.
O'DONNELL BREATH SAILORS. OKAY
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES THE
ACTION FOR SUB COMMITTEE- THE
FOR THE YEAR WE WILL WE HAVE
SOME OF THE OTHER ITEMS WILL
COME BACK TO THE FULL COMMITTEE
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION WE DO HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENTS I BELIEVE SO.
NOBODY HERE YEAH BEFORE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS WE HAVE SOME
VOTE ADJUSTMENTS SO WE WILL
STAND BY PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
JUST A SECOND.
HELLO ADJUSTMENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GALLAGHER HE
YES WITH REGARD TO THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE ITEM. YOU
ARE NUMBER SIXTEEN NOW. OKAY
NOTED. OKAY THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS
MODERATOR YOU THERE. SOMMAIRE
YES DO WE HAVE TO HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE. YES WE DO HI NEED DELISH
WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE
AT THIS TIME. IN THIS PAST MAY
THIRTY SIX IN Q. A START OFF
WITH- LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE BRENNAMAN I'M WITH
MONTEREY COUNTY ANIMAL SERVICES
AND I'M CALLING TO URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FORTY FIVE
MILLION FOR ANIMAL SHELTER
GRANT PROGRAMS AT UC DAVIS
CALIFORNIANS GOALS THAT NOW
ADOPTABLE ARE TREATABLE ANIMAL
SHOULD BE EUTHANIZED IS ONE
SHARED BY ALL ANIMAL WELFARE
PROFESSIONALS. WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
ANIMALS AND PEOPLE AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. STRATEGICALLY
ALLOCATED RESOURCES FROM THE
STATE WILL BE HELPFUL IN MOVING
TOWARD THE STATED POLICY
OBJECTIVES WE URGE THE STATE TO
STEP IN WITH THIS NEW SUPPORT
FOR EXPERTISE AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICANA LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THIS IS
JUST HAN STEVEN BUT PUBLIC
ADVOCATE- WHAT THE COURT OF
STUDENT FOCUS PRIORITIES THE
QUICKLY- BUT BASIC NEEDS AN
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUND AS THEY
ARE REFLECTED IN THE UC. CSU
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET
PACKAGES. AND WE CONTINUE TO
URGE THE ASSEMBLY AND
ADMINISTRATION TO GO FURTHER
AND ATTRACTING IT NEEDS BY
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CAL GRANT
AND ADOPTING THE CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION AN EQUITY
FRAMEWORK AS LAID OUT IN AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SECOND. AND JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
CHAIR FOR CONTINUING TO
PRIORITIZE HOW GRANT WITH
MARTIN. THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KATE HURLEY AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CORRECTIONAL TO
MEDICINE PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS.
THE PROPOSED TO ANIMAL SHELTER
SUPPORT PROGRAM IS NOT JUST AN
ANIMAL ISSUE. IT IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE WE NOW KNOW WHAT IT TAKES
TO MEET THE STATE'S CALL THAT
NO HEALTHIER TREATABLE PET BE
EUTHANIZED AT THE SHELTER. AND
YET MANY SHELTERS IN OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES STILL LACK
THE WHEREWITHAL TO KEEP PETS
HEALTHY. SAFE AND HOME WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. IN THE VERY
SAME PLACES ARE COLD AND HIT
THE HARDEST AND PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING ANIMALS ARE LOSING
THEIR LIVES AT A HIGHER RATE.
THIS EXACT A PUBLIC SAFETY AND
MENTAL HEALTH COST THAT IS
BORNE BY PEOPLE AND FAMILIES IN
THESE COMMUNITIES. IT'S A ONE
TIME FIVE YEAR INVESTMENT WOULD
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL
COMBINATION OF TRAINING AND
RESOURCES. FOR EVERY SHELTER IN
EVERY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
URBAN AND RURAL NORTH SOUTH AND
CENTRAL. TO SUCCEED IN THEIR
CRITICAL WORK THROUGH THE CODE
RECOVERY AND BEYOND. IN
ALIGNMENT WITH OUR STATE HUMANE
VALUES AND TWENTY YEAR OLD
POLICY GOAL. I URGE YOU TO
RECONSIDER THE DECISION TO
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE GOT TO FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH AT YEAH
YOU WERE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT FROM
CHILD CARE- IN ADDITION TO
THOSE INCLUDING THE MAYOR OF
PATIENTS AS WELL THE PEOPLE ARE
RGA WE'LL MINOR COMMENT ON
ATTENTION CARE AND WITH OUR
ALLIES AND GET TO THE NEW RATE
IN OUR LETTER PARTICULARLY ON
INSURANCE PROVIDERS ARE
INCLUDING THE CONVERSATION AND
RESOURCES ARE GIVEN TO
STABILIZE OUR PROVIDERS MOVING
FORWARD. ON BEHALF OF ACT YEAH
YOU WE APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION
OF CUSTODIAL STAFF AND A
CONCENTRATION GRANT ALTHOUGH WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE DOLLARS
SPECIFIC TO THOSE WORKERS WERE
ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF THAT
CHANGES MADE SAID COCKFIGHT THE
MARKETING PROGRAM- WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ONGOING DOLLARS TO
BETTER STABILIZE THE PROGRAM OF
THE FORWARD- AND WE WOULD ALSO%
ASK FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
DIRECTED TOWARD UNIVERSAL MEAL-
WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON THE
COMMUNITY FOR PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE WE BEST UTILIZE OUR
EXISTING COUNTY SOCIAL SAFETY
NET SERVICES. AND FINALLY I'M
HIGHER AND WE WERE DISAPPOINTED
IN THE LACK OF SUPPORT
INVESTMENT AROUND LABOR
ESPECIALLY AT THE FACULTY
SUPPORT STAFF OF WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO HELP ADAPT
CAMPUSES DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
WOULD URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
IMPACT MY DRAFTING MEMBERS AND
PROBLEMS DUE TO A LACK OF MERIT
SYSTEM WOULD HAVE CUT BACK.
THAT WE DO THANK YOU. WE ARE
DEADLINE THIRTEEN. PLEASE AHEAD.
YES THIS IS TRACY MORE ANIMAL
SERVICES MANAGER FOR THE CITY
OF CHICO I RUN A SMALL
MUNICIPAL SHELTER IN BUTTE
COUNTY AND I ASK THAT YOU
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR AN ANIMAL SHELTER
GRANT PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS. OUR
COMMUNITY WAS STILL TRYING TO
RECOVER FROM THE CAMPFIRE. THE
HOUSING CHALLENGES IT CREATED
AND THE LOSS OF VETERINARIANS
WHEN THE PANDEMIC HIT THE
PANDEMIC FURTHER REDUCED ACCESS
TO VETERINARY CARE FOR BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND THE SHELTER. THE
NORTH COMPLEX FIRE DURING THE
PANDEMIC JUST COMPOUNDED THESE
ISSUES. SHELTERS WILL CONTINUE
TO BE IMPACTED AS HOUSING
BECOMES LESS AFFORDABLE AND
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR HOMES DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC AND WILDFIRES OR
OWNERS CANNOT ACCEPT THAT IN
EVERY CARE FORCING THEM TO GIVE
UP THEIR PASSED. THE SHELTER
GRANT PROGRAM WILL BE A MUCH
NEEDED BOOST FOR STATE SHELTERS
TO ASSIST WITH RECOVERY FROM
THE PANDEMIC PROVIDE RESPONSE
DURING DISASTERS. PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR COMMUNITIES AND
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES TO
MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF ANIMALS
WHOSE LIVES ARE SAFE THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY
FIVE. GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SUSAN RECKLESS ASPCA I URGE-
COMMITTEE ASKING THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
GOVERNOR ISN'T INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET YOU- SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
SHELTERS- THE FIGHT HERE AT ONE
TIME FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOCATED
OVER FIVE YEARS ALL CALIFORNIA
SHELTERS AND REACHING AND
SUSTAINING BAR THE INEQUALITY
GOAL THAT NO HEALTHIER ANIMAL
SHOULD BE EUTHANIZED. IN
ADDITION IT APPLIES EXPERTISE
OF THE UC DAVIS CORRECT PROGRAM
AND THAT IS REALLY NATIONALLY
KNOWN AS AN EXPERT IN- APPLYING
THE BEST PRACTICES YOU ENSURE
THAT. THE NEEDS CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED. IN THE STATE THANK
YOU. YEAHSO THE TWO LINES ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR TO AND MEMBERS BRED TAYLOR
ON BEHALF OF FEDERAL WITH THE
ABOUT DOWN ON OF THE TWELVE TO
FOR WHICH IS GOING TO IMPORTANT
FOR US TO BE AND FUNDING GOING
FOR ONCE FOR STRAPPED. SO WE
ALSO THE ACT ON THE MY PROPOSAL
TO INCREASE CAREER TECHNICAL
AND FUNDING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN I'LL BE HAPPY
EXTENDED OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS
SERVICES ASSOCIATION WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE ADDITIONAL
TWENTY MILLION ON GOING TO UPS.
THIS INVESTMENT IN EQUITY WILL
ALLOW UPS OR EVEN MORE STUDENTS
REACH THEIR GOALS. ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WITH THE PORTANTINO WE
APPRECIATE THE 5% COLA
EXTENDING THE HOLD HARMLESS THE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
THE FUNDING CALIBRATE. AND
ESPECIALLY THE TOTAL TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR
PART TIME FACULTY SUPPORT FULL
TIME FACULTY HIRING. THIS
INVESTMENT IN FACULTY WILL OUR
SYSTEM MAKES NIPPING AT
PROGRESS IN INCREASING FACULTY
DIVERSITY HIRING MORE
COUNSELORS AND SUPPORTING OUR
PART TIME FACULTY WHICH ALLOW
OUR ACTIVISTS BETTER SERVICE
UNITS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR INCREDIBLE SUPPORT
COMMUNITY. COLLEGE FACULTY AND
STUDENTS. MEXICO TO LINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
THE NAME COBURN CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION OUR
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
ESSENTIAL AND I'M LOS INCOME
FAMILIES THE FACT THAT THE
CHILD CARE AND OTHER NEEDED
FAMILY SUPPORT. FIRST OFF I'M A
NUMBER MCCARTY NUMBERS THAT THE
COMMUNITY IN YOUR STAFF THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR PUTTING FORWARD
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL POSITIVELY IMPACT FAMILIES
AND PROVIDERS. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH FOR INCLUDING YOUR PLAN
REIMBURSED BREAK A FORM SHOULD
BRING REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
PROVIDERS UP FROM POVERTY LEVEL
EXPANDING LICENSE CHILD CARE
CAPACITY AT HIGH NEED
COMMUNITIES. CAPTAIN FAMILY
SEASON INCREASING ELIGIBILITY
FOR ALL ISRAEL LIFE YOUR
PRIORITY FOR THE FURTHER
EROSION OF THE CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE WE APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY PLAN TO FUND AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED THOUSAND
FLOCKED 285% OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ARE MARC AND NICOLA TO
FOUR OH FIVE. IF THE INCREASE
IS BLOCKED RICHARD FOR THE RATE
INCREASE WE ALSO ASK THAT THERE
BE PATIENT A ONE TIME GRANT
MONEY. FOR AGENCIES TO BEGIN
IMMEDIATELY RAMPING UP FOR
FAMILY INVOLVEMENT THE INCREASE
PLATFORM WILL MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE EXISTING CAPACITY OF A
COMMUNITY PROGRAM WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS FAMILIES
WILL BE UNABLE TO ACCESS THESE
NEW SLOT. WE BELIEVE THAT IF
YOU INCREASE THE RATE AND
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR CONTRACTORS
TO RAMP UP THEN WE WILL BE ABLE
TO ENROLL ANY NUMBER OF SLOTS
THAT YOU MAKE AVAILABLE IN
ADDITION TO THE ABOVE WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR PRIORITIES
WITH THOSE OF THE EASY CALL
THIS AND AGAIN OUR HEARTFELT
APPRECIATION. THANK YOU. THANKS
TO THE TIMELINE A TWO. PLEASE
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER MINOR IS
ERICA. AND I'M ON BEHALF OF THE
LOW INCOME INVEST FUND WE ARE
MEMBERS THE EASY COALITION AND-
THAT CALIFORNIA COULD ASIAN WE
EXT OUR- FOR YOUR FROM TO
SUPPORT THE VERY L. THAT ARE.
FOR THIS OF K. AND IT'S FIELD
AS EXPRESS BY COME MEMBERS-
EARLIER THIS MAY IT IS THAT
HE'S HOME. THANKS FOR ACHIEVING
POWER TO MAKING BACK THAT WE
HAVE THE ECHO FOR A DAY.
REGARDING ITEM RELATED TO PASS
AND EXPAND LICENSE CHECK AT
CAPACITY WITH LIKE TO. THANK
YOU MYSTIC. FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND THEY WORK HERE IS HOME
BUILDING AND ALL THE GO OVER
MAYOR. THAT ABOUT AND MEADOW UP.
IT PROCESS. IF APPROVED THE
NAME STEP UP THE BY PROCESS IS.
SACRAMENTO INCREASED. PROMOTE
HEALTH CENTER AND BE A CAPACITY
AMONG PRO. IRAQ TODAY WILL IT
EASY FOR OUR ACROSS THE STATE
TO ENSURE THAT AND WITH. DAN
HAVE FAITH AND QUALITY. WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO MAKE THEIR DAY PROPOSED
APPROVED TODAY AS PART OF THE
BUDGET TO BE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PATTING HER ON
BEHALF OF EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIA
WE WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR INCLUDING AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
UNIVERSAL LIFE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND ADDING SOME
CRITICAL QUALITY COMPONENTS.
OKAY SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
OUR FOUR YEAR OLD STUDENT ARE
MET WITH HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION
IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR THEM WE ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE ROBUST
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE SYSTEM TO THE
ADDITIONAL SPOTS AND THE RATE
ON THAT THE RATE INCREASES THAT
WERE PROVIDED IN YOUR PACKAGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT TO
THE TO LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ANTOINETTE PELLETIER AND I'M
THE CHAIR FOR THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE WISH TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF THE COMMITTEE
AND THE STAFF FOR THE FANTASTIC
BUDGET PROPOSAL WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THIS HISTORIC
LEVEL OF SUPPORT AND FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION. EARLY
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL AND FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE VOICE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE OUT OF HOME
CARE FUNDING SOLUTIONS AND WE
ARE EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE FOR
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION CO THAT
REALLY FUN. AT THE PROJECTED
COSTS FOR REPLACEMENT OR MAKE
UP SERVICES FOR STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL EDUCATION NEEDS DUE TO
COVER THEM TAX. COULD BE AS
HIGH AS THREE BILLION DOLLARS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THE ALLOCATION FOR THAT ITEM BE
INCREASED BY FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN FOR THIS AMAZING AND
HISTORIC BUDGET OF SUPPORT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. SO THAT'S
LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS APPLICANTS REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION I WILL HIGHLIGHT
JUST A FEW PARTY ISSUE FROM THE
INTEREST OF TIME ON ISSUE ONE
ON ITEM ONE ISSUES FIVE TO WAIT
STATE PRESCHOOL AND UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
ITEM TO ISSUE ONE ON CHILD CARE
ACCESS. TO SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT ALLOWS
STATE PRESCHOOL TO PROVIDE FULL
DAY FOR BEER CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
FIFTY K. AND KINDERGARTEN
STUDENTS WILL ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT PROVISIONS TO MAINTAIN
CHILD ELIGIBILITY IMPACT CHOSE.
FOR STAPLES COHEN HEAD START.
WE SUPPORT RECOMMENDED FOR
PLEASE CLOSE AND WITH. AND A
PRE THE STAFF AND COMMITTEES
WORKING AREA. ON ITEM ONE ISSUE
CAN TWELVE THE SUPPORT SPECIAL
RECOMMENDED AND ITEM THIRTEEN
TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION WE KNOW
THAT IN. POINT COUNTING IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED- AT THIS
TIME AS WELL AS THE PROPOSAL TO
PAY DOWN ALL K. TWELVE DEFAULT.
LASTLY I'M ISSUE TWENTY TWO WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL AMENDED
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING. WE
HAVE SEEN THE IMPACT COMMUNITY
SCHOOL TO PATTERN OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR OTHER ITEMS IN YOUR PACKAGE
THAT WE SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
AND FOLLOWING UP. WITH A LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
NEXT IN HEADLINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JOANNA FRIENDS I'M ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH AND POLICY
AND IF A PUBLIC POOL WE
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ASKING YOU TO IN FACT FEDERAL
FUNDS DIRECTLY AND NON
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
AFTER SCHOOL LEARNING AND
SUMMER ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO SUPPORT STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING AND ACCELERATE LEARNING.
WE'RE FACING AN ENORMOUS
CHALLENGE AND WE KNOW THAT BOTH
CANNOT DO THIS ALONE THE
PHYSICALLY WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
SET ASIDE ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN TO BE MADE DIRECTLY
AVAILABLE FOR NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING AFTER SCHOOL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. I WITH THE FUNDS
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY LOCAL
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION WE
ALSO ASK THAT YOU PROVIDE A
CALL INCREASE FOR THE AFTER
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND SAFETY
PROGRAMS AND TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY COMMUNITY LEARNING
CENTERS USING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING RATHER
THAN AT THE AMERICAN MATTHEW I
PLAN DOLLARS. WE ALSO ASK THAT
YOU PASSED AB ELEVEN TWELVE AND
INVEST THAT WE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT GRANT PROGRAM WE
ALSO INVITE ALL OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO ATTEND A COMMUNITY
FORUMS NIGHT WITH SENATOR LARRY
PENDER QUITE CATCHY AND OTHER
LEGISLATORS AT. FIVE THIRTY PM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES MY NAME
THREE YEAR LIVE. FIVE MILLION
ATTENTION LADDER AND I AM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
HUMANE SOCIETY AND NOT SHASTA
CALIFORNIA. WE NEED HELP WE
WORK TIRELESSLY TO ME ALMOG
NEED EVERY DAY TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. THIS NEW SUPPORT FOR THE
EXPERTISE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS
FIND IT THE STATE. ATTENTION
AND I REALLY URGE THE ASSEMBLY
JOB THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR
AN ANIMAL SHELTER GRANT
PROGRAMS IF YOU DAY THAT. THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT ANIMALS THIS
IS ABOUT PEOPLE IT'S ABOUT
CHILDREN. EIGHT ZERO SIX YOU
COUNTY OUR BIGGEST PROGRAM
RELATED TO THE PUBLIC IT IS
CHILDREN AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM. THE HIGH SCHOOL-
SENIOR PROJECT WE HAVE JUST
BEEN HERE. ALL THE TIME
SPONSORING HUGE HUGE HUGE
PROGRAM HERE THE FAMILY BEING
ABLE TO POSSIBLY KITTEN.
SCIENTISTS PROVED THAT ANIMALS
ARE HEALTHY FOR US WE NEED THEM
AND I LIVE IN THE CHILDREN THE
DAMAGE YOUR GROW ACT WITH
COMPASSION AND KINDNESS. AND
AGES. HELLO MY- AND WE REALLY
YOU ARE OUR ACCOUNT URGENCY WE
ARE IN A BIT. BIGGER COUNTY AND-
TELEPHONE. AND WE- HAVE A VERY
HIGH. OF UNDERSERVED PEOPLE AND
SMALL WE NEED SUPPORT UP HERE
TO ANYBODY WOULD REALLY BE ABLE
TO HELP MY CHILDREN WITH IT
WOULD BE GRANTED WOULD
COMFORTABLY REALLY AREN'T YOU
CLEAN. ASSEMBLY APPROVED
OPPOSE. TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THE GRANT PROGRAM. I NEED TO
DATE I THINK HE'LL- NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE. NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS KELLY
AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR SHOWING CONNIE
HERE TO URGE YOU ALL TO
RECONSIDER THE ELIMINATION OF
COVERAGE FINDING WE BELIEVE OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY AND COMMUNITIES
ARE BEST SERVED BY HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT IS
EQUITABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND THIS INCLUDES
THE STATE SIX POINT EIGHT
MILLION ADULTS TWENTY FIVE TO
FIFTY FOUR. WHO HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA BUT NO COLLEGE
DEGREE IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS NOT
DESIGNED TO THIRTY STUDENTS AND
AFTER CALGARY COMES IN
RECOGNIZING RESPONSIBILITIES
THESE ADULTS DIDN'T STRUGGLE
OUTSIDE THEIR COURSEWORK
INCLUDING BALANCING FAMILY OVER
QUITE. WHICH ARE MAJOR BARRIERS
THAT PREVENT THEM FROM
ATTENDING COLLEGE INCLUDING A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CALGARY
OFFERS A LOW TO NO COST SKILLS
BASED EDUCATION THAT ALLOWS
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE COURSES AT
THEIR OWN PACE. BY MAKING HELP
BRING OPERATIVES THE
LEGISLATURE TAKES AWAY A
CRITICAL TOOL FROM THE
CALIFORNIANS COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND RISKS REPEATING THE
MISTAKES OF PAST RECESSION
LEAVING NO CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
THIS FLEXIBLE ACCESSIBLE.
PATHWAY INTO GOOD JOBS THANK
YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
NINETY FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH SEVERAL
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE C. P. U.
W. WE APPRECIATE THE STRONG
LEADERSHIP AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON THE EARLY EDUCATION PACKAGE
PARTICULAR AROUND ADDITIONAL
SPOT RATE WAITING FAMILY PETER
SUPPORT FOR THE CPU AGREEMENT
SPECIALLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REACHING FOR BARGAINING
CONTRACT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK. MEXICO TO LINE ONE
OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN
MEMBERS SPINSTER WITH CHILDREN
NOW TO BE BRIEF BUT WANT TO
SPEAK TO A FEW OF OUR
PRIORITIES BUT FIRST THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED A NUMBER OF
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS ACROSS
THE BROADER PROGRAMS WE BELIEVE
IT'S ESSENTIAL TO CREATE
COHERENCE ACROSS. TO THAT END
WE RECOMMEND A MINING PLANNING
TIMELINE BEEN INTEGRATING
PLANNING REQUIREMENTS BUILDING
ON THE L. CAP OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE STAKEHOLDERS AND A CLEAR
WAY ENGAGE IN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE ADEQUATE
FINANCIAL REPORTING FOR THIS
PROGRAM SO POLICYMAKERS CAN
FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW FUNDS WERE
SPENT IN COULD BENEFIT
BENEFITTED FROM THE SERVICES
PROVIDED. THAT WITH RESPECT
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WE
SUPPORT THE STEPS THE ASSEMBLY
PLAN TAKES TO ADDRESS BREAK
REFORM IN ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE
AND POLITICALLY SCHOOL STOCKS-
WITH REGARD TO THE EXPANDED
LEARNING PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE
IT'S ESSENTIAL TO EXPAND BEYOND
CASE SIX OF I PROGRAMS
DEVELOPED MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND THEN
FINALLY- WITH REGARD FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION WE SUPPORT INCREASED
INVESTMENTS IN THE FORM OF THE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
OUTLINED IN ITEMS EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
BUT WORK STRONGLY EMPHASIZE
PROVIDING AID TO COVER THE FULL
COST. OF POST SECONDARY
ATTENDANCE THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO KAREN THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS PHILIP ZIMMERMAN I AM
THE MANAGER OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTRY ANIMAL
SHELTER AND I AM CALLING TO
URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO APPROVE
THE GOVERNOR'S ORIGINAL OPPOSE
FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
ANIMAL SHELTER GRANTS PROGRAM
AT UC DAVIS SHELTER CORRECT
MEDICINE PROGRAM CALIFORNIA'S
GOAL THAT NO ADAPTABLE OR
TREATABLE ANIMALS SHOULD BE
EUTHANIZED IS ONE SHARED BY ALL
ANIMAL FOR PROFESSIONALS.
WORKING KIND OF IT TIRELESSLY
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF ANIMALS
AND PEOPLE IN THEIR COMMUNITY
THIS ONE TIME FUNDING
STRATEGICALLY ALLOCATED
RESOURCES FROM THE STATE WILL
BE HELPFUL IN MOVING TOWARD THE
STATED POLICY OBJECTIVES WE
URGE THE STATE TO STEP IN WITH
THE SUPPORT FOR EXPERTISE IN
GRANT FUNDS WHICH WILL IMPACT
OUR MOST UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. TO GO TO
LINE WHO WON TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH
TAKEN ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY ON
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET
PACKAGE WE ARE OPPOSED TO ITEMS
THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE THE
PROJECTION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE CONTRACT THE
PATHWAYS AND REDUCING FUNDING
FOR ADEQUATE IMPLEMENTATION BY
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
CRITICAL OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
STREAMLINED PATHWAY THROUGH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR
GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS.
ENSURING THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE SUPPORTED BY CLEAR
PATHWAY A LIPSTICK STUDENT
SERVICES AND COMPREHENSIVE
PATHWAY MAPPING IS PARTICULARLY
URGENT WHEN CONSIDERING THE
CONTACT LOW TRANSFER RATE.
AMONG STUDENTS WITH DATA
TRANSFER GOALS ONLY 19%
TRANSFER WITHIN FOUR YEARS AND
TWENTY EIGHT BUT THEN SIX
YEARS. ON ISSUE NUMBER FOR THAT
THE FACT BUDGET PACKAGE WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER THE
EACH REQUIRE HIGH SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE STUDENTS FILL OUT
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS
CALLED PORTABILITY THE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER FACING LOW
INCOME STUDENTS A CHALLENGE
WHICH CAN BE ADDRESSED IN PART
BY INTENTIONALLY ATTRACTING.
AND INCREASING STUDENT
UTILIZATION OF AVAILABLE
FEDERAL EIGHT WE WOULD ALSO
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO INCLUDE
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT IN THE
CAL GRANT COULD YOU WORK OUT
PROPOSED BY THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION INTO THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THIS WOULD REMOVE
BARRIERS TO FINANCIALLY CREATED
BY EACH TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
GPA. OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS.
FINANCIAL AID. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME LEADERSHIP. NEXT TO
THE LINE FIFTY SIX. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ROBIN LADEN
WITH EDUCATIONAL RICHMOND
SYSTEMS WERE NONPROFIT CENTER
BASED ORGANIZATION IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SERVING THIRTEEN HUNDRED
FAMILIES AND THEIR CHILDREN
AGES BIRTH THROUGH ENTRANCE TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AT TWENTY TWO
CEST PNCC T. R. CENTERS WE
SERVE FULL DAY YEAR ROUND AT
ELEVEN HOURS TWELVE MONTHS AS
WELL WHAT PART DAY PART YEAR.
WE STAYED OPEN BOTH- IN PERSON
AND DISTANCE LEARNING FARMSTAND
SO WORKERS WE ALSO EMPLOY A
HUNDRED AND NINETY EMPLOYEES
THAT CURRENTLY DO NOT MAKE A
LIVE A LIVABLE WAGE AND NOT
LEAVE THEIR HOME EVERY DAY TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND PUT THEIR LIFE ON
THE LINE DURING COLD IT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ADDING PARENT
CHOICE FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS. TO
REMAIN AND PSPP. ON THANK YOU
FOR THAT LET ITEMS. TWO AND THE
ENTIRE ISSUE TO IN THIS. EARLY
EDUCATION PASSED NOT THE
SPECIALLY THE RATE REFORM
PROPOSAL SO WE CAN GET CLOSER
TO THAT LIVING WAGE FOR OUR
CHILD CARE WORKFORCE. AND THANK
YOU FOR CONTINUING TO HOLD
HARMLESS. WE WOULD NOT BE OPEN
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING. WITHOUT
WITHOUT DISTURBING ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- WITH THIS- DURING COPE
IT THIS IS MY THIRTY SEVENTH
YEAR AND SEEN THE DARK EASY
PROPOSAL IS VERY. VERY AMAZING
AND- IT IS JUST MAKING CAREER
SWITCH YOU AGAIN. FOR TO US ALL
OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS-
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF US ON THE
GROUND DOING THE GOOD WORK
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR THE TWO
LINES ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI AIR NAPPY WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES COMMENTING ON THE
KITAP DISCUSSION ITEMS WE
SUPPORTED ME REVISED ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
YEAH YES THAT CONCENTRATION
GRANT BY RAISING THE RATE 265%
ENERGY ASSEMBLY TO ADOPT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL RATHER THAN
THE LEGISLATURE IS MORE MODEST
UP OR MENTAL GRANT INCREASE.
WITH THE FOR THE FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN EXPANDED
LEARNING I REQUEST THAT ACCESS
BE EXPANDED TO INCLUDE SERVICES
FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND NOT LIMITED TO
ONLY KINDERGARTEN THROUGH SIXTH
GRADE. WE URGE YOU TO MAINTAIN
THE THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS INCLUDED IN A
REVISED COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ARE A
LINCHPIN TO TRANSFORMING SCHOOL
CULTURE AND CREATING SYSTEMIC
CHANGE WE RECOMMEND ALLOCATING
AT LEAST 5% OF FUNDS SET ASIDE
FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING INCLUDING
FUNDING TO SCALE SERVICES. THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS PROGRAM
SHOULD BE ALIGNED TO THE FOUR
PILLARS OF COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AT
THE TIME THAT THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL LEYVA AND GRANTEES
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO CO CREATE
A COMMUNITY FOR PLAN WITH
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ANNUALLY
UPDATED AT A PUBLIC MEETING.
LASTLY WE SUPPORT THE ME
REVISED PROPOSALS INVESTING IN
EDUCATORS MEANT TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
OPPOSE THE ASSEMBLY SUBSTANTIAL
REDUCTION IN DC TEACHER QUALITY
INVESTMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE BUDGET AND FOR
CONSIDERING A RECOMMENDATION.
MEXICO TO LIE. SEVENTY EIGHT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN TO
MEMBER THIS IS MARSHALL WITH
THE STANDARD YOU WITH TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ACTION ON
ITEM SIX FOUR FOUR ZERO NUMBER
THREE FOCUSING THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF TIGHTENING
RESPONSIVE TO THE OVERWHELMING
STRESS AND HARDSHIP. THAT
DIDN'T SUCH AS MYSELF HAVE BEEN
UNDER LOCK COMPLETING OUR
EDUCATION DURING THE PANDA
ADDITIONALLY THE RIGHT MEETING
THAT WILL BE AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC AS EVER BY THE START
OF THE I APPROACH YOU KNOW
AMERICANS IN AND OTHER ASIAN
AMERICANS DIDN'T HAVE THE PACE.
WATCHED IN THEIR EMPRESS'S BUT
WHILE WE'RE JUST TO DO AND EVER
CLASS IN THE- PLEASE TELL WILL
STILL EVEN AT THE THREE AT THE
GREAT BY ON THE K. THANK INTO
ALSO SUPPORTED HIM ACTION.
INVESTING IN MONTHS HELP THEY
CAN GET YOU I DON'T THINK
CONDONE THREE THANK YOU YOUR
CALL I DON'T THINK EIGHT SEVEN
ZERO THAT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SACRAMENTO MARTIN ON
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE VERY
EXCITED THAT THE GOVERNOR MAY
READ INCLUDED ARE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE CREATION OF AN L. G. B.
PLUS TRAINING PROCEDURE AND
SCHOOL STAFF. WERE ALSO
INCREDIBLY GREAT THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADVANCED PORTION THEIR
BY TODAY- REFERENCE AN ITEM. ON
P. SIXTY FOUR ON- HOWEVER WE'RE
NOT TO LIVE A RARE TO THE OF
THE INTENDED IN THE NAVY. AND
WELCOME BY THE OF AND I MEAN
FOR LET. WHICH WE ALSO HAVE
THAT SOMEONE SO I KNOW THERE
ARE A LOT OF MOVING TO HERE SO
WE WELCOME ANY IN CONTACTS AND
JUST WANTED TO ELEVATE ALL THE
PEOPLE ARE POOR AND I THINK
TRAGIC SECTION USE ME- URGENT
BACKGROUND OF. REQUEST FOR
THREE NINE I WE ALL IT THANK
ALL OF MEMBERS AND THE STOCK
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS DURING A
VERY BUSY. TIME THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO WHO WANT NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
NUMBER THIS IS ERIN I'LL ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTH MINUTES
DIRECT FIRST LIKE TO THE CAN
FOR A COMBAT TO WITH DOES THAT
AND APPRECIATE YOUR HAS IN THE
IN SPECIAL ED. INCLUDING ONE A
LOT RECOVER GRANT BUT BASS
REDUCTION IN FAMILY AND CENTERS
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
AND MORE RELATED TO THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION LEARNING RECOVERY
GRANT. OUR PRELIMINARY DATA
ACTUALLY SHOWS THE COST OF
SERVICES AND THE SPEED
REVOLUTION MAY EVEN EXCEED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS INVESTMENT AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THIS IMPORTANT SPECIAL
EDUCATION. FUNDING AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT. MEXICO TO LINE
ONE OH FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS EVENING
RODRIGUEZ FROM EDUCATION TRUST
WHAT FIRST WE'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY CAPACITY PROPOSAL
SUCH AS THE PROSECUTOR
COMPLETION PUSHING YOUR STUDENT
FUNDING FOR STATE THAT PROGRAM
AND HIGHER EDUCATION MEDICINE
WOULD RESPOND. CHOOSING TO THE
POINT WE ASK YOU SOMEBODY ALSO
THE ONES FURTHER TO SUPPORT CAL
GRANT EQUITY BRING ONE. I
SUPPOSE BUT STUDENT TO MAKE-
FOUNDATION ON ANY FOR AID. IN
THE YEAR'S BUDGET- ONLY
CONSIDER LIKE HELP COULD NOT BE-
THE POPE TO ALL HIGH SCHOOLS
COMPLETE BOXER KITA NEED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT ANY NEW
OPPORTUNITY IS ABLE TO ENSURE
YOU STUDENT CENTERED AND
EQUITABLE FINANCIAL AID CLICK
ON. WILL BE URGING LEGISLATURE
TO REFORM BACK TOWARDS THAT
APPLE FINANCIALLY COULD COMBINE
NOT BEING THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK IN THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING ARGUE AT
LEAST CONVERSATION ON
FINANCIALLY CRIPPLING CONTINUES
BETWEEN. THE ASSEMBLY. THANK
YOU. THANKS TIMELINE ONE
TWENTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. CREATE
A LEGO CHILDCARE LAWCENTER WE
GREATLY THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR
THE CHILD CARE PROPOSAL YOU
HAVE HEARD THE VOICE OF THE
PARENTS CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND THE EASY COALITION LOUD AND
CLEAR WHICH IS REFLECTED IN
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT UNDER ITEM TWO
ISSUES ONE THREE FIVE. SIX
SEVEN EIGHT NINE TEN AND ELEVEN
AND ESPECIALLY ISSUES RELATED
TO INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT
RATES TO PROVIDERS INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF CHILD CARE SPACES
OKAY A LOT AND EXTENDING THE
WAIVERS FAMILY FEES WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE DIDN'T SEE
THE FEDERAL CHILD CARE
CIVILIZATION FUNDING EXPLICITLY
ADDRESSED IN THIS PROPOSAL.
PLEASE NOTE THIS MONEY CAN BE
USED FOR VERY SPECIFIC PURPOSES
TO SUPPORT PRIVATE AND PUBLICLY
FUNDED CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
STAY OPEN AND PAY FOR COSTS
RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER HAS SUBMITTED
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL CHILD
CARE GRANTS. WE HAVE VOICED OUR
CONCERNS REGARDING THE TIKI
PROPOSAL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
AND OTHER MEMBERS ON THIS
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE MAXIMUM
RENTAL CHOICE AND THAT A
DIVERSE GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN ON THE BALLOT OF THE- I
CURRENTLY WRITTEN FIFTY CAPER.
IN THIS LEAVES OUT NOT THE P.
P. CENTER IT'S FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND SAN FRIEND
NEIGHBOR. WE HAVE SHE OUR
PROPOSED THEM TO DO SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN PARENTS AND
FAMILIES. MEXICO TO LINE OF ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON JACK.
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHT CHIRLA-
JUST WANTED THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT IS DONE TO
MAKE SURE THAT I DOCUMENTED THE.
IMPACT HIGHER EDUCATION- AND
HOW ACCESS TO RESOURCE THEY
NEED TO COMPLETE THE EDUCATION
EXACTLY. AND IN PARTICULAR
WANTED THE ADDAMS THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE IN. LEGAL IN THE
SUPPORT THAT AND ALL REALLY
KIDS THAT CAN FOR. APPROVAL AND
THEN THE REVISION PROPOSAL FROM
THE GOVERNOR TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE DREAMER
RESOURCE LIAISON PROGRAM FIVE
TO FIVE POINT EIGHT MILLION ON
GOING WE SEVERAL. WITHIN OUR
MEMBERSHIP WHO WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THESE PROGRAMS THAT
CONTINUALLY TELL US THAT ON
THEIR CAMPUSES THEY HAVE FOLKS
WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO BE THERE
FULL TIME. AND THEN THEY ARE
NOT ABLE TO BUILD CONSISTENT
RELATIONSHIP. CONFLICT THAT
BEAT INTELLECTUAL TO OPERATE ON
A CAMPUS AND WE TRULY BELIEVE
THAT CONTINUING INCREASE
ONGOING FUNDING WILL HELP
REALLY CENTERPIECE PROGRAM AND
GET IT AND- THE PERMANENCY THAT
THEY NEED. FOR THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT TO THE TIMELINE TO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTER-
CHAIRMAN THE AND OUR STEAM EDGE
COMMITTEE LEGISLATORS MY NAME
IS MIKE WAGNER I AM A CALDERON
AND DEMO BOARD MEMBER OF A
LOCAL ANIMAL RESCUE GROUP HERE
IN DISTRICT FOURTEEN IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THE STATE PASSED
THE HAYDEN ACT WHICH WAS
SUPPOSED TO DRIVE OR STATE
TOWARDS BECOMING A NO KILL
STATE. BUT THAT ACT WAS TO
FUNDED IN THE GREAT RECESSION
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
FUNDING WAS NEVER RESTORED. IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OUR
SHELTERS EUTHANIZED ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ANIMALS
EQUALLY TROUBLING IS THE FACT
THAT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
OUR COUNTY SHELTERS IN THE
STATE HAVE NO ON PREMISE THAT
CARE. SADLY THERE'S A
DISCONNECT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PERCEPTION OF STANDARD OF CARE
AT ALL COUNTY ANIMAL SHELTERS.
HERE IN MY CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
WHICH IS THOUGHT TO BE A WELL
OFF. DEMOGRAPHIC AREA WITH THE
MEDIAN HOME. PRICE OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OR COUNTY
ANIMAL SHELTER HAS A COST PER
CAPITA OF ONLY SIX DOLLARS AND
THIRTY EIGHT CENTS. THIS IS IN
STARK CONTRAST TO THAT OF OUR
NEIGHBORS TO THE NORTH IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THAT ENJOYED
A COST PER CAPITA OF FOURTEEN
AND A HALF DOLLARS. I URGE YOU
TO APPROVE THE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR AN
ANIMAL GRANT PROGRAM AS
ADMINISTERED BY UC DAVIS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE DON'T LEAVE
OUR SHELTERS BEHIND THEY ARE
VERY IMPORTANT MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. LET'S GO
TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS KAREN LAYING TOP OF
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING MANY
OF THE SHELTERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN WITH AFTERNOON I
JUST FEEL REALLY UNDERSCORE
THAT THE HIDDEN MANDATE WHEN IT
WAS SUSPENDED- TOOK ALL STATE
FUNDING AWAY FROM- CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SHELTERS SO. ALL OF THE
SHELTER OPERATIONS YOU SEE ARE
YOU'RE SITTING COUNTY SHELTERS
ARE FUNDED ENTIRELY THROUGH
CITY COUNTY GENERAL FUND AND
THROUGH ADOPTION FEES THAT ARE
ORDINARILY SET MUCH LOWER THAN
THE COST OF CARING FOR THE
ANIMAL BECAUSE WE WANT PEOPLE
TO COME IN AND ADOPT. SOTHIS
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR WAS
INTENDED AND IS INTENDED TO
HELP DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
REDUCE EUTHANASIA AND SHELTERS
AND THAT'S THE ONLY REAL MONEY
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THIRTEEN
YEARS. SO WHEN YOU'RE SAYING
AND I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
COMPARING THAT TO OUR EDUCATION
PRIORITIES- BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TO PUT IT
IF YOU SEEN IT BEFORE YOU AND
THE SUB COMMITTEE BUT THERE'S
LITERALLY NO OTHER SUB
COMMITTEE THAT WHEN. MAKE ANY
OTHER DECISIONS ABOUT SHELTER
FUNDING THIS IS THE PRECEDENT
BEEN THE ONLY THING FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS SO IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE UNDER SO MUCH HOPE AND
NOW THAT I YOU'VE ACTED TODAY
TO REJECT IT THERE'S A LOT OF
DISAPPOINTMENT AND WE'RE HOPING
YOU WILL REVISIT. YOUR DECISION
AND THE FINAL NEGOTIATIONS THAT
ARE STILL TO TAKE PLACE AT THE
END OF THE DAY THE ANIMALS ARE
CARING FOR ARE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AS WELL AS-
ANIMALS THAT DON'T BELONG TO
ANYBODY AND ARE GOING TO GET
HOME THIRDS THERE YOUR
CONSTITUENT ANIMALS SO PLEASE
PLEASE RECONSIDER WHEN YOU
GOING TO FINAL. NEGOTIATIONS
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO SIXTY NINE
PLEASE AHEAD. IT'S NOT. IN
ORDER FOR. ONE SIXTY NINE YEAR
IS OPEN. THE ONE ON THE LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
HEALED AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DOCTOR RESCUE. ONLY
TWENTY TWO YEARS OF OUR
EXISTENCE WE RESCUED THOUSANDS
OF DOGS FROM SHELTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SHELTERS DO THE
ABSOLUTE BEST THAT THEY CAN
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE BUT THEY ARE ALL VERY
OVERWHELMED AND THEY COULD DO
SO MUCH MORE IF WE HAD THE
SUPPORT OF THE UC DAVIS SHELTER
GRANT PROGRAM. I URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO REVISIT AND APPROVE
THE GOVERNOR'S A REGIONAL FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
FOR THIS PROGRAM. AS MANY
OTHERS SPEAKERS OF SAID
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE GOAL
THAT NO ADOPTABLE OR TREATABLE
ANIMAL SHOULD BE EUTHANIZED BUT
THEY ARE. IN SHELTERS CANNOT
POSSIBLY MEET THAT GOAL UNLESS
THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDES
PROFESSIONAL AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE SHELTER
PROGRAM. ALSO PLEASE KNOW THAT
IS THE CODE RESTRICTIONS ARE
RELAXING AND PEOPLE ARE GOING
BACK TO WORK WE ARE ALREADY
SEEING AN INFLUX OF ANIMALS
SURRENDERED TO THE SHELTER.
MOHAMMED GANDHI SAID THE
GREATNESS OF A NATION CAN BE
MADE HERE BY THE WAY ANIMALS
ARE TREATED. FOR MANY REASONS I
BELIEVE THAT AMERICA HAS LOST A
LOT OF THE GREATNESS. THE
CALIFORNIA IS STILL ON THE
FOREFRONT OF PROGRESSIVE
THOUGHT AND PROGRESSIVE CHANGE.
I URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO STEP IN
AND SUPPORT THE SHELTER
PROGRAM. AND FULFILL A NEED
THAT ALL OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
SHELTERS ARE EXPERIENCING. ANY
OVERALL BUDGET PICTURE THE
GOVERNOR IS ASKING FOR A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT. THANK YOU. MEXICO
TO MIND ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TONY
DEADLINE AT WORK WITHIN A DAY
PUBLIC SCHOOL WE REPRESENT
HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WHO
ASKED ME TO INVEST FEDERAL
FUNDS DIRECTLY IN COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDING AFTER SCHOOL LEARNING
AND SUMMER ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. YOU'RE TAKING ON
THE CHALLENGE. AND WE KNOW THAT
SCHOOLS CAN'T DO IT ALONE
PHYSICALLY WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
SET ASIDE ONE POINT ONE BILLION
FROM AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. HE
MADE DIRECTLY AVAILABLE FOR
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. PROVIDING AFTER
SCHOOL LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
TO WERE ALSO HAPPY TO PROVIDE A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR
THE ACES AND TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY LEARNING CENTER PROGRAM
USING PROP NINETY FUNDING.
THIRD JOAQUIN A PATH AB ELEVEN
TWELVE TO STABILIZE AFTER
SCHOOL AND SUMMER PROGRAMS AND
FINALLY INVEST AT LEAST TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNING TO MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES ACT GRANT PROGRAM. AND
WE BUY ALL THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO A COMMUNITY FORUM FOR
HOSTING TONIGHT WITH SENATOR
LARRY. SENATOR CORTESE IN OTHER
LEGISLATORS AT FIVE THIRTY YOU
CAN REGISTER AT GO TO INNOVATE
SCHOOL DOT ORG. FORWARD SLASH.
EIGHT S. R. T. THANK YOU. NOT
TO GO TO LINE SEVENTEEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS ELIZABETH ORIC CALLING ON
BEHALF OF BEST FRIENDS AIMAL
SOCIETY AND OUR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS SUPPORTERS
PARTNERS AND STAFF IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR FUNDING FOR THE UC DAVIS
ANIMAL SHELTER GRANT PROGRAMS
WHICH THE SUBCOMMITTEE
UNFORTUNATELY VOTED TO REJECT
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
WERE THE BUDGETING NEEDS RIGHT
NOW BUT THIS TOO IS A PROFOUND
NEED FOR OUR STATE AND IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT PAT. IT'S ABOUT
PROVIDING CRITICAL SUPPORT IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S ABOUT TAXPAYERS TO
SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF SHELTERS
TAKING IN ANIMALS HOUSING THEM
AND EUTHANIZING THEM WHEN THEY
AREN'T ADOPTED MORE ANIMALS ARE
DYING IN CALIFORNIA SHELTERS
THAN IN ANY OTHER STATE SO THIS
FUNDING IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
FOR PATH. TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
NOT TO KILL ANY HEALTHY OR
TREATABLE ANIMAL FOR SPACE SO
WE URGE A RECONSIDERATION OF
THIS ITEM. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT TO THE TO LINE
ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL STEWART AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE CALVET
FACULTY AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIBRATE ACADEMIC SENATE. I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
RECOMMENDATION ON ISSUE TWENTY
AT SOME POINT THE CONTINUED
FUNDING OF COMPLEX COLLEGE.
PARK FACULTY TEAM IS WORKING
EVERY DAY TO SUPPORT OUR DOOR
ADULT LEARNERS THROUGHOUT BATES
BARRIERS TO TRAINING IN THE
PAST. AND THIS IS CRITICAL WORK
AS WE BUILD A MORE EQUITABLE
RECOVERY. FOR THE STATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY INTERNET
KONAMI HAVE AT STUDENT CENTER
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE OFFICIAL VOICE OF
THE TWO BUT ONE MILLION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS I'M
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS THAT
AFFAIRS AND A STUDENT FULL
SOMEBODY COLLEGE WE THANK AND
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE'S
ADOPTION OF MANY OF THE
STUDENTS ARE PROPOSALS.
INCLUDING BAKING NEEDS AN
EMERGENCY GRANTS HOWEVER WE
URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO BE FIERCE
IN OUR ADVOCACY FOR CAN RECALL
STUDENT HOUSING AND THE CALVERT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS PROGRESS. HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS STUDENTS ARE
DISCRIMINATED UNDER OUR CURRENT
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM. WE CANNOT
ALLOW THIS TO CONTINUE THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH IT'LL COME
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE TOP
RIGHT FACULTY AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CAL GREAT
ACADEMIC STANDING I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THE
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE FUN CAL
BRIGHT COLLEGE OUR FACULTY TEAM
IS WORKING EVERY DAY TO SUPPORT
ADULT LEARNERS THE STATE
COUNCIL BARRIERS TO GETTING AN
EDUCATION IN THE PAST AND HOW
GREAT SELECTABLE PAINTING IS
VITAL TO THEIR SUCCESS BUSINESS
CRITICAL WORK AS WE BUILD A
MORE EQUITABLE RECOVERY. FOR
THE STATE. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MR CARE MEMBERS NICK
WRONGLY CALLING ON BEHALF OF K.
ROB THE CESSATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS
JUST VERY QUICKLY WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE- FOR
THE WORK IN THE PROPOSAL TO ADD
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDS TO THE C. T.
INCENTIVE GRANT- AND ALSO JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR THANKS- TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL FOR
HIS CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN THE
AREA. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY ANY UNIT THIS IS DONNA
HOFFMAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COUNCIL BIRTH DRAWN AMERICA
REPRESENTING FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS READY NATION AND
MISSION READINESS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIR
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE HISTORICAL INVESTMENTS IN
THE EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
SYSTEM BASICALLY HEARING THE
FEEDBACK FROM FAMILIES
PROVIDERS IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
ARTISTRY CARE ACT CALIFORNIA WE
ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE EXTRA
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SPOT WILL SERVE THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MOST IN
NEED AS WELL AS THE WAITING A
FAMILY SKI THAT WILL INCREASE
AFFORDABILITY FOR FAMILIES
CREATING A SYSTEM. THAT IS MORE
JUST EQUITABLE IN SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATION WE ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR SINCERE GRATITUDE
FOR YOUR ADDITION OF
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM IN
THE ASSEMBLY PACKAGE WE CANNOT
BUILD A STRONG EASY SYSTEM
WITHOUT PAYING PROVIDERS WHAT
THEIR WORK WE ALIGN OUR OTHER
PRIORITIES WITH THOSE OF THE
EASY COALITION AND WE WANT TO
GET APPRECIATE AND RECOGNIZE
THE HISTORICAL INVESTMENT PUT
FORWARD TODAY FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES. AND PROVIDER. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANKS FOR
THE TO. ONE TWO. EIGHT PLEASE
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BASICALLY ON BEHALF OF
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE STATE WIDE
COLLEGE WRONGFUL. WARNS OF
STRONG SUPPORT ISSUE ONE IN
ABOUT NINETY PACKAGE THE
PERFECTLY SPECIAL PROGRAM
NUMBER FOURTEEN OF EIGHTY G.
COMPLETION GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM SHOULD BE
ACCEPTABLE TO ALL AND WITH
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
INVESTMENT WITH THE COURT
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. ACROSS
THE STATE THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAMIE METAL
HYBRID HEADSTART CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE HEAD START
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE OVER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES ANNUALLY
EMPLOYING OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TEACHERS WITHOUT EIGHT
WHITE THANK YOU MR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERING HEAD START AT THE
STATE MOVES FORWARD AND HE
CAN'T EXPANSION. WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT WE CONTINUE COULD BE
CONSIDERED PART OF THAT MAKE
THE LIBERTY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSING TODAY'S HEARING AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT HEAD START DOES NOT GET
LEFT BEHIND AS HE TAKES
EMPLOYMENT AT. PROTECT PROGRAMS
YOU'RE NOT AT RISK CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THAT EARLY LEARNING
AND WRAPAROUND SERVICES THE
AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS THAT
THIS PACKAGE NEEDS TO ADDRESS
THE COSTS EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE TEA CAKES
MANSION. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST SUPPORT FOR FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR PREPARATION
WHICH HE COMMITTED BUDGET LAST
WEEK PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT THE
LOCAL PROGRAM COULD YOU CAN YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO REACH MORE
CHILDREN AND EARLY HEAD START
HEAD START MIGRANT AND SEASONAL
HEAD START AND AMERICAN INDIAN
HEADSTART. PROGRAMS ARE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED FOR HIGH
QUALITY WHOLE CHILD WHOLE
FAMILY APPROACH AND FOUNDATIONS
OF INCREASING RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC EQUITY WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FISCAL SUPPORT
EQUITABLE TO THE SUPPORT
PROVIDED OTHER PARTS OF THE
NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM THE
ABILITY OF HEAD START PROGRAMS
TO ACCOMMODATE SEEKING
EXPANSION WILL BE JEOPARDIZED.
LASTLY WE WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMON CAN PRIORITIES WITH
THE ECB COALITION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TAX. CONNECT THE
DEADLINE. ONE TWENTY TWO. PLAY
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JUDY
MAN KUSI AND I AM THE FOUNDER
PRESIDENT CEO SOCIAL COMPASSION
IN LEGISLATION AND WE ARE IN
FAVOR OF THE ANIMAL GRANT
PROGRAM THAT YOU. NUKED FROM
THE BUDGET AND- FIELD THAT IT
SHOULD BE RECONSIDERED- WE SENT
A LETTER TO YOU THAT- THERE
SHOULD BE- VERY SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE IN IT A RIGHT NOT
REFERENCES THAT'S PRACTICES
AND- BEST PRACTICES- CAN CHANGE
CAN BE. JEFF SAYS- WE BELIEVE
THIS MONEY SHOULD GO TO SPAY
NEUTERING MICROCHIP THEME- SO
THAT WE CAN PREVENT THE ANIMALS
FROM GOING INTO THE SHELTERS OR
GETTING BACK HOME ONCE THEY'RE
THERE SO DID SPEND IT ON THE
FRONT AND- THE BACK AND- WE ARE
THE CREATOR OF THE ONLY FUNDING
MECHANISM IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
CALLED THE PET LOVERS LICENSE
PLATE. WE STARTED ON THIS
PLAYED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT I GOT ON THE ROAD IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND NOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PER YEAR GO TO SHELTERS
FOR SPAY AND NEUTER HOWEVER
THAT IS THE ONLY FUNDING
MECHANISM- BUT CITED TAX CHECK
OFF WHICH GENERATES A
NEGLIGIBLE AMOUNT. SO THE
FUNDING IS SORELY NEEDED IT WAS
TAKEN AWAY YEARS AGO BECAUSE
THE STATE WAS IN THE RED NOW
THE STATE IS IN A SOLID BLACK
AND THE GOVERNOR IS GENEROUS
ENOUGH TO GIVE SOME OF THIS
MONEY BACK. AND IT NEEDS TO BE
THERE AND TIME HAS CALMED IT'S
BEEN UP AND IT IS JUST REALLY
UNFORTUNATE THAT YOUR COMMITTEE
JUST COMPLETELY REJECTED IT SO
PLEASE RECONSIDER WHEN YOU GO
TO CONFERENCE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT TO LINE ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FOR THE JOB ALONE BUT IT THAT
THE PROJECT CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS FROM SLOTS TO
INCLUSION OF REIMBURSEMENT
RATES SO EVEN FOR STRUCTURE
EASY DATA DASHBOARD FUNDING
ALLOCATED FOR IMPLICIT BIAS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
OPEN YOUR GRADE LEVEL BUILT
WITH TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
COUPLE COUPLE THINGS WE BELIEVE
CHEN STILL BE IMPROVED UPON WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
HOW TO BEST IMPLEMENTATION
KINDERGARTEN IN A WAY THAT IS
EQUITABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FIRST
TO OUR STUDENTS WHO BENEFIT
FROM LTFS CONCENTRATION. GRATZ
I THINK WE ALL AGREED THAT OUR
NEEDIEST STUDENTS WHO BENEFIT
THE MOST FROM MOST STUDENT
TEACHER RATIOS AND DEVELOPMENT
WITH THE APPROPRIATE TICKET
CURRICULUM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON HOW TO BEST
IMPLEMENT SUCH. PRACTICES TO
MEET THOSE NEEDS. WELCOME TO
PART OF A YOUR STORE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. IN COMMITTEE
SCHOOL. PROPOSED BY THE- BUT
THE ASSEMBLY AS THE VERSION- OF
A LINE WITH HEALTH START. WHICH
HOPE CAN BE ACCEPTABLE PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE OUR STATE'S YOUNGEST
CHILDREN AS WELL. WE BELIEVE
HOLISTIC AND COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICES FOCUSED ON WHOLE CHILD
CALLED FAMILY ARE ABSOLUTELY
TERRIFIED INVESTMENT TO BE
MADE. WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
SURE SUCH INVESTMENTS ARE MADE.
IN THIS BUDGET YEAR AND BEYOND
AND MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON T.
K. AND Q. AND MAJORITY LEADER
EVERY US FOR BEING CHAMPIONS
FOR ELECTRIFICATION ISSUE SINCE
THEY WON. EXAGGERATION FOR
COMING THIS FAR- I'M GETTING
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS ARE
YOUNGEST. LEARNERS AND STUDENTS
OF COLOR THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
ON THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ADAM STEIN REPRESENTING
THE CELL BUT MINISTRATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SNOW COUNTY
SALPA- I WOULD LIKE TO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THIS INCREDIBLY AND-
IMPACTFUL AND HISTORIC
EDUCATION BUDGET. AND
SPECIFICALLY FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE'RE IN GREAT
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER THREE IN
THE T. K. TWELVE PACKAGE WHICH
IS- EARLY INTERVENTION
PRESCHOOL GRANTS FOR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION WE WOULD JUST
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER- ESTATE PUTTING INTO
AN ALREADY ESTABLISHED FUNDING
MECHANISM INSTEAD OF CREATING A
SEPARATE ONE- BUT AND THEN WE
ARE ALSO IN VERY MUCH IN FAVOR
IN SUPPORT. OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR FOR COVERT
RELIEF IN THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE NUMBER ELEVEN- WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO RESPECTIVELY WERE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AS WE KNOW THAT THE
COST TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
BE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ONE
BILLION AND TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS TO THE TO LINE ONE
ELEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ASHLEY ODELL AND I
AM A FACULTY MEMBER AT CALVARY
COLLEGE AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIBRATE FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
FORTY OPPOSED A RECOMMENDATION
ON ISSUE TWENTY. FOUR CAN YOU
CONTINUED FUNDING OF CALIBRATE
COLLEGE. OUR TACKLE GA ARE
DEDICATED TO HELPING THE POOR
UNDER RESOURCE ADULT GAINES
GUILD TO IMPROVE THEIR- THEIR
UPWARD MOBILITY THEREBY
INCREASING THE LEARNERS
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
HELPING SUPPORT THE STATE PATH
TO RECOVERY THANK YOU. MEXICO
TO LINE ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HENRY
BURKE CALLED ME I'M HERE
QUALITY MANAGER VERY HELPFUL
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I'M CALLING
TO VOICE THE VERY HELPFUL FOR
CONTINUED SUPPORT COVER COLLEGE
AND OPPOSE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
WHICH WAS AND STILL MANY OF OUR
COLLEGE. COVER CONFIDENTIAL
RESOURCE FOR CALIFORNIANS
WORKING ADULT STUDENTS WHO NEED
A SELF FIFTY EDUCATIONAL MODEL
THE BALANCE WORK CHILDCARE
FAMILY AND OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES EDUCATED IN
THE RECENT STATE PADA OPERATE
IS NOT DUPLICATE OF THE
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND DESERVES SEVEN YEARS
STARTUP TIMELINE INITIALLY SET
OUT OF OUR READ IT. NOW IS THE
TIME TO MEET WORKING ADULTS
WHERE THEY ARE AND WE THE TOP
RIGHT DO THAT AND YOU CAN BE A
RESOURCE YOU ARE ALL THE PARTS.
NOT WORKING CLASS. HELLO
SUPPORT CONTINUED FUND COVERED.
OWES AND NUMBER TWENTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MICHAEL TO MY AT
ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AT
THE SAME WITH NEXT AND CAL- THE
T. K. TO PACKAGE ISSUED I WANT
TO FIVE WE THINK THE COMMITTEES
TO OF FAST CUTICLE FOR THAT ALL
ARE TAX CRITICAL FOR-
ADDITIONAL READ RESPECTFULLY-
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE
CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK AS
OUTLINED IN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS ON THE REMOVING
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS TO
FINANCIAL AID AND SIMPLIFYING
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURING THE STATE
MOVES FORWARD WITH DEBT FREE
COLLEGE. FINALLY UNDER ISSUE
THREE FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PEPOSE ITEM TWENTY AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE ASSEMBLY
TO RECONSIDER THE ELIMINATION
OF CALIBRATE ALL TOO OFTEN
WORKING ADULTS LOOKING TO
UPSKILL AND IMPROVE THEIR
ECONOMIC PROSPECTS TURN TO
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
WE HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE
ENROLLMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC
WILL ROAM IT HAS DECLINED
ACROSS ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
CALGARY OFFERS THE PUBLIC
STRUCTURE THAT PROVIDES
STUDENTS WITH MUCH NEEDED
CLASSROOM COLLECTABILITY
OPPORTUNITY. TO IMPROVE THEIR
SKILLS AND THE ABILITY TO
PURSUE A EDUCATION THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE TWO ONE FORTY
SEVEN. PLEASE BUT- MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILL BE A
BELIEVE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER ONE L.
EIGHT REGARDING UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEAL FUNDING- THIS IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDING. AND WE AND GIVEN THE
HIGH. RATES OF STUDENT STUDENT
ID AT THE WE ARE THE AT THE TO
A IT THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JIM APPEARING
FOR THE SAME DIEGO HE MAY
SOCIETY AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
AND. EXPRESSING PRINCIER THE
POINT WITH THE SAID RIDGE OF
THE FIVE YEAR DOLLAR SHOP GRANT
AND FOR YOU DAVIS. THE PAST
YEARS CRY THAT UNDERSCORED THE
ESSENTIAL ANIMALS- PLAY AN
ARCHIVE OR RECOVERY EFFORTS WE
PROVIDED CARE FOR PETS PEOPLE
WHO ARE HOSPITALIZED THE CODE
NINETEEN FOUND WAY TO DELIVER
PET FOOD SAFELY. TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOMEBOUND HOUSING ANIMALS
FOR PEOPLE TO BY Y. AND ADD A
PANDEMIC TO PER A CRITICAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY MAN
SEX INJURED AND ANIMALS THE
BURDEN OF DISASTERS OF ALWAYS
SELL THE COMMUNITIES WITH THE
MODEM HIM POPPY. AND ANIMAL
SHELTER CHRIS WORSE TO ME SUCH
AS IN THE THIS ONE INVEST WOULD
PROVIDE HANDS ON ASSESSMENT TRY
FROM THE NATION SHELLED EXPERT
AND FINANCIAL RESOURCES THE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR TO A LIFE FOR
PETS IN SUPPORT PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES TO RECOVER AND BEYOND.
WE STRONGLY A OF THIS I IN
BUDGET OR CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
THANK. NEXT TO THE LINE WE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KRISTEN BROWN HERE UNIT OF
EDUCATE ACROSS PROFESSION THE
METS THING FOR ALL THE WORK
DONE ON THE CALL FOR CREDIT
SOME OFFICE FOR PRIESTS PHONED
AND FUNDING ALSO THE LGBT POST-
BIG HI TO YOU FOR THE WHICH
WILL PER QUE. REALLY
REALLOCATING THOSE RESOURCES TO
THE CURRENT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WHICH IS IN DIRE NEED
AND THE C. TO UPGRADE- IS ALSO
VERY WELL APPRECIATED WE HAVE
SUBMITTED OUR LETTER TO STAFF
IN YOUR IN YOUR OFFICES TODAY
OUTLINING A COUPLE OTHER ISSUES
DEALING WITH ADULT EDUCATION
CARRY OVER. A VERY SMALL ISSUE
THE PERSONNEL COMMISSION
REGARDING COMPTON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
OTHER MEMBERS ON WHAT HAPPENS
WITH VIRTUAL LEARNING AND
INDEPENDENT STUDY- WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT KEEPING SOME OPTION FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE NOT PEOPLE
WERE READY TO COME BACK TO IN
PERSON LEARNING IN THE FALL AND
LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THOSE ISSUES THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NEXT TO MY- ONE THIRTY
FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRING COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS VERONICA COAT AND THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
TAME A COUNTY SULFA AND I'D
LIKE TO ALIGN MYSELF AND MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
INTERNET PUBLIC HEREEVENT AND
ADAM STEIN AND THINKING THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR
THEIR TREMENDOUS SUPPORT AND
FUNDING RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION. I SUPPORT
ALL SPECIAL EDUCATION ITEMS IN
THE BUDGET INCLUDING THE OUT OF
HOME CARE FUNDING MODEL AND THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
EARLY INTERVENTION GRANT- ADDS
ADAM STEIN DEFINED TO WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE THAT- IN THE
EXISTING FUNDING MODEL INSTEAD
OF ESTABLISHING ANOTHER FUNDING
MODEL. AND IN RELATION TO THAT
COATED- LEARNING RECOVERY GRANT
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
WE REALLY ARE AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO SEE THAT INVESTMENT BUT WE
HE- POTENTIAL CLAIMS AND THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE
RATE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
AND THANK YOU AGAIN TO YOUR
STAFF AND ALL OF YOU FOR THE
TREMENDOUS- AND HISTORIC
BUDGET. THANK YOU. CONNECT TO
THE TIMELINE. ONE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- YES THIS IS
LATIF DECKER HERE WITH
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEES PLAN TO FUND
UNIVERSAL T. K. AS WELL AS
INCREASED LOTS PER CHILD CARE.
AND INVESTMENTS AND RATE
PERFORMED AND WAVING- AND THE
WAITER ON FAMILY FEES AT TO
BEGIN TO REINVEST AND REBUILD-
TO STATE EARLY CHILDHOOD.
EDUCATION SYSTEM WE ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
CHAMPIONING THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EFFORTS FOR MANY
YEARS AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GRAY IS ALSO CHAMPIONING. THE
NEEDS OF CHILD CARE THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO JANELLE AND
THEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA DOCUMENTED HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION ON MAJOR
ITEM ISSUE THREE THROUGH
COLLEGE BUDGET BUDGET PACKAGE
WE ARE MORE OF NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT AND FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE HIRING OF ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND EVERY CALIFORNIA MAKE
COLLEGE CAMPUS. AFFECTED
RESERVING A DOCK INTO EVERY
MORNING AT EIGHT. ON K. TWELVE
THE ONLY ISSUE CHU J. R. TWELVE
TWELVE AYE TRAILER BILL WE ARE
MORE OF A NUMBER ONE TWO FIVE
REQUIRING LEN BIR NOT ALL HIGH
SCHOOL. MEET I THANK THAT OUR
CAT I. AND THE ADDITION MEMBERS
INSURING FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED.
STUDENTS I FINALLY THE AREN'T
THE PART OF HIGHER EDUCATION
BILL ONLY I NOT. THE GRANT
IMMIGRATION LEGAL. YOU NEVER
CAL AND LEGAL SERVICES CENTER
CONTINUE TO DO THAT THAT MUCH.
CLASS PROVIDING ASSISTANCE YOU
IT BACKGROUND MADE- THE NEW
YORK TIMES ON AN ONGOING BASIS
TO USE AND THAT BY. STABILITY
OF THE GULF. AND IT'S CREDIT
ATHLETE BOB TAKE MORE THAN A
YEAR TO BE CALLED. I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND TO GET
I. THANKS FOR THE TO LINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THIS IS A THREE
YOUR DILEMMA HOW THIRTY YEAR
COUNSELOR TO SOME SERVER. AND
I'M HERE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THE TO YEAR MAKING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. UP ARE IN
THE- WE TRULY APPRECIATE THE
INCREASE IN THEIR MERGER
POINTING MASON AT IN YOUR PIECE
I THANK YOU FOR. WITH DIRECTLY
IMPACTS OUR MOST ON THE
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS COLOR.
ACTUALLY WE BUT ONLY ASK THAT
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE WE CAN IN.
CAMPUS OFFICE REQUIRE THE FIRM
THE AFTERNOON MADE EDUCATION
NET AND- CALLED AS ONE YOU MAY
DOLLAR WHICH PROVIDE STUDENTS
IN MAY FROM MEN IN BATON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
DONALD JOB AFTERNOON I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO EVERYTHING YOU'VE
BEEN SAYING I'M SO HAPPY FOR
THE BUDGET YOU'RE ABOUT TO
APPROVE THANK YOU SO. MUCH IN
ADVANCE FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
NOT TO GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS NO NORTH DELGADO AND
I'M THE EDUCATION MANAGER FOR
PALO ALTO HUMANE SOCIETY IN
PALO ALTO AND SERVING THE
LARGER MID PENINSULA I'M
CALLING TO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO RECONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FORTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR AN ANIMAL SHELTER
GRANTS PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS.
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL IS THAT NO
ADOPTABLE OR TREATABLE ANIMAL
SHOULD BE EUTHANIZED AND THAT
GOAL IS ONE THAT'S SHARED BY
ALL ANIMAL WORLD FOR WELFARE
PROFESSIONALS WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
ANIMALS AND PEOPLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. NOT PROVIDING
RESEARCH RESOURCES IS PLACING
AN UNDUE BURDEN ON THE MOST
NEEDY OF OUR COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED MOST BY THE
PANDEMIC. THESE PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT THEIR ANIMALS AND THESE
ANIMALS NEED OUR HELP. OF
RESOURCES FROM THE STATE WOULD
BE HELPFUL IN MOVING FORWARD
THIS POLICY OBJECTIVES THAT WE
ALL AGREE WITH AND WE URGE THE
STATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE TO RECONSIDER THEIR
REJECTION OF THIS PLAN. THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE MODERATOR IN
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AT TODAY'S THE
FINAL. SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING BUT
AS YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVE SOME
OTHER. ISSUES TO ADDRESS NEXT
WEEK AND FOR COMMITTEE AND THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS NEVER OVER
UNTIL WE DROP THE FINAL BUDGET.
IN YOU KNOW IN JUNE. WITH THAT
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION AND WE WILL